Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und begrüße alle zur 106. Ausgabe von Raumzeit.
Gab eine kleine Pause. Jetzt machen wir wieder weiter und ähm ja heute ähm kommt mal wieder eine der wenigen Follow-up Folgen, die ich hier bisher gemacht habe. Manche Themen.
Ähm bedürfen einer gewissen Nacharbeit und das war so eins, wo ich mir dachte, da kann man auf jeden Fall nochmal nachfragen. Ich beziehe mich nämlich auf die Sendung sechsundsiebzig, der Geier Sternkatalog.
Wurde veröffentlicht am 8 siebten zwanzig neunzehn, also vor dreieinhalb Jahren und dieser Sternkatalog äh ist und war damals auch schon work and progress
und deswegen habe ich nochmal Stefan Jordan eingeladen, um weiter Auskunft zu geben. Hallo Stefan.
Ja, herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Ein weiteres Mal. Da wir schon letzte Mal so viel ähm über die
dahinterstehende Technik gesprochen haben und so weiter, kann man vor allem erstmal hier auf die alte Sendung verweisen, sprich wenn ihr die nicht gehört habt oder vielleicht nicht mehr so richtig im Ohr habt, das wäre äh optimal
erstmal reinzuhören und hier auf Pause zu drücken und wir schließen dann mehr oder weniger direkt dran an, aber trotzdem können wir vielleicht nochmal kurz was zu dir sagen.
Du bist ja nach wie vor beim astronomischen Recheninstitut in Heidelberg.
Und da hat sich auch wenig dran geändert in den letzten drei Jahren in der Tätigkeit.
Ja, also an der Tätigkeit hat sich nicht sehr viel geändert und wir sind natürlich nach wie vor dabei,
dass die Daten des Katalogs uns jeden Tag anzugucken mit das ist ja ein Team was das auch in Heidelberg macht. Die machen einen First Look, die gucken die Daten an und ähm messen die Datenqualität
wird äh beschäftigen wir uns auch mit Datenbanken, mit Visualisierung, mit äh
Beobachtung von Gaja, vom Erdboden aus, um den Orbit richtig zu bestimmen,
und die Leitung des ähm des der des Core Processing, also der hauptsächlichen Astrometrischen
Dinge, die findet auch in Gaja statt, das heißt also unser Team ist nach wie vor dabei in Heidelberg das,
ist nach wie vor dabei äh an mehreren Fronten sozusagen das äh Projekt zu unterstützen
Zusätzlich gibt's natürlich zum Beispiel in Deutschland äh eine Gruppe in Potsdam und in Dresden, die dabei ist und international arbeiten ja in insgesamt 400 Wissenschaftler und
Softwareingenieure daran äh mit den Daten ähm weitere ähm ja ja weitere Daten zu produzieren, die dann auch Astronomen äh benutzen können.
Also Heidelberg ist Gaya Central sozusagen.
Nein, das kann man nicht sagen. Also das äh Zentrum ist äh in vielerlei Hinsicht äh aufgeteilt äh und in verschiedene Gruppen, je nachdem, mit welchem Bereich sich man sich innerhalb von Gaja beschäftigt, aber im Bereich der Astrometrie ist es in der Tat, dass das bei uns von
Michael Biermann zum Beispiel die dieser Teil geleitet wird und andere Gruppen sitzen eben in verschiedenen
teilen Europas und äh ja die Oberaufsicht hat dann natürlich noch die ESA und äh verschiedene Gremien innerhalb von
dem äh Konsortium, den und das für die Produktion des Sternkatalogs zuständig ist und.
Ja also wie gesagt da gibt's keine Zentren aber wir sind die größte Gruppe innerhalb von Deutschland das kann man sagen ja.
Zwanzig neun1, zwanzig zweiundzwanzig, da ist ja was äh passiert zwischendurch. Wie sehr hat euch so die ganze Corona äh Krise bei der Arbeit gehindert.
Ja, sie hat uns die Arbeit nicht äh.
Unmöglich gemacht, aber es ist natürlich schwieriger. Also wir haben natürlich schon vorher fast alle Kommunikationen mit Hilfe von Videokonferenzen gemacht, weil es eben auch ein Projekt ist, was über ganz.
Europa verstreut ist, aber es war immer nützlich.
Wenn man sich auch mal trifft. Und sei es abends mal auf dem Bier zu treffen, dass man eben das motiviert auch unheimlich, weil man sozusagen dann auch persönliche Beziehungen aufbaut zwischen den einzelnen,
und äh äh das manchmal ist es auch leichter, mal in einem auf einem Meeting dann
Kaffeepause mit jemandem zu reden, als dass man sozusagen eine offizielle Konferenz hat, auf der man redet. Das heißt, die Kommunikation ist an dieser Stelle äh schwieriger geworden, aber das Gute ist vielleicht
im Schlechten, äh dass das Gajaprojekt ja jetzt schon eine ganze Weile läuft und die meisten Leute sind schon von Anfang an beim Gaja-Prü,
gewesen. Die kennen ja die Leute und haben auch schon mal mit denen sozusagen persönlich zu tun gehabt. Schwieriger ist es für neue Leute, weil für die äh sind das manchmal ganz abstrakte Personen, die sie vielleicht auch manchmal nur von der Stimme her kennen und äh das ist sicherlich
ungünstig, aber trotzdem sind wir da glaube ich sehr professionell und versuchen mit Hilfe von äh Videokonferenzen die Kommunikation doch so weit aufrecht zu erhalten
trotzdem kann man sagen, paar Monate Verzögerung hat's wahrscheinlich dadurch gegeben am Ende, das muss man sagen und äh natürlich gab's auch immer mal Leute, die dann
Corona direkt auch ausgefallen sind, einige Wochen dann und äh also es ist nicht spurlos an uns vorbeigegangen, aber wir konnten damit halbwegs äh.
Klar kommen und kommen auch nach wie vor klar. Inzwischen ist es so, dass es auch wieder die ein oder anderen persönlichen Treffen gibt, aber die sind immer noch in der Minderheit.
Filtern so mal so ein bisschen so dieses.
Unerwartete, ne? So diese äh klar wenn man weiß, worüber man reden will und solche Videokonferenzen haben immer so diesen Fokus, ne, da will man dann irgendwie auch keine Zeit äh vergeuden, aber manchmal kommen ja die wirklich richtig guten Ideen eher so nebenbei. Ne.
Das gilt übrigens auch sogar innerhalb unserer Gruppe am Ari. Ich meine, da sind viele dann auch im Homeoffice. Auch ich bin weitgehend im Homeoffice gewesen
und äh man hat sich früher dann eher beim Mittagessen getroffen und hat man da auch spontan mal irgendwas angesprochen, was man wahrscheinlich in einem äh Meeting wo ein klarer Plan für das Meeting vorlag, dann äh gar nicht besprechen würde. Also äh das das sind durchaus auch viele negative Seiten, die damit zu tun hängen.
Ja weniger Wissenschaft mangels Trash-Talk.
Wir sind eigentlich sehr stolz, dass wir das trotz allem ganz gut hingekriegt haben.
Ja äh trotz des Verweises auf die alte Sendung sollten wir vielleicht nochmal kurz den Rahmen aufspannen, indem wir jetzt uns hier unterhalten. Wir reden also vor allem über die Ergebnisse der Raumsonde.
Gaja, die Dezember 2013 gestartet wurde. Eine Mission zur Vermessung des,
als primär der Milchstraße, aber teilweise eben auch darüber hinaus. Ähm seit hm weiß nicht, ging dann irgendwie ein Jahr später ungefähr halb.
Los, ne, also.
Die offiziellen Messungen begannen dann im Juli äh 2tausendvierzehn
und zwischen dem Staat und der ähm Ankunft im am L2, das ist ja der Beobachtungsort, äh der 1,5 Millionen Kilometer von der Erde entfernt ist äh an dem Gaja die Messungen dann durchführt in einem
bestimmten Orbit, äh würden natürlich zunächst einmal sozusagen Gaja auf Herz und Nieren geprüft, vermessen und kalibriert äh und auch da hat übrigens äh Heidelberg sehr viel.
Durch den First look, der damals natürlich eine ganz besondere Bewandtnis hat und im Juli begann dann die Messung. Das heißt, da heute auch Gaja immer noch Mist haben wir jetzt acht, ein Drittel Jahr
Messung.
Das ist äh schon so einiges, ne? Fünf Jahre waren mal so mindestens angedacht und die Hoffnung lag auf zehn Jahren und sieht jetzt auch so ein bisschen danach aus
dass das auch äh erreicht werden konnte. Also als wir die letzte Sendung aufgenommen haben, war nämlich das nominale Missionsende erreicht
und dann ist aber verlängert worden bis Ende 20, dann nochmal verlängert worden, bis Ende 2undzwanzig. Das läuft also jetzt quasi gerade auch aus.
Also bis 24 haben wir die äh Genehmigung, muss man dazu.
Also das muss ja immer auch Geld zur Verfügung gestellt werden, weil natürlich die auch die Betreuung einer Mission natürlich äh zum Beispiel Bodenstation Zeit kostet und
vielleicht noch ein bisschen später eingehe, ist es so, dass obwohl wir äh inzwischen ja natürlich einen gewissen Routine mit den Geierdaten haben, versuchen wir immer noch die
das Verständnis der Daten zu verbessern und die Qualität der Daten dadurch zu verbessern, dass wir
bessere Kalibrationen machen und systematische Fehler, wie man sie nennt, reduziert. Das heißt, da muss immer noch eine ganze Menge Gehirnschmalz rein äh fließen und das bedeutet natürlich, dass auf Seiten der ESA bei der Raumschiffbetreuung
ähm äh Geld fließen muss und natürlich auch für die Auswertung der Daten natürlich noch.
Da sein muss, aber äh das wird immer in Scheiben von zwei Jahren verlängert. Das ist nie so, dass sie sagen, wir verlängern jetzt mal für fünf Jahre, sondern das wird immer sozusagen, dass es ähm Standard bei der Es.
Budget-Meeting sozusagen.
Und dann heißt es natürlich, dass wir dann auch für den Rest äh der Mission äh auch nochmal äh natürlich eine Genehmigung haben wollen. Also wir rechnen damit, dass wir bis
April 225 messen kann, dann werden nämlich die Ressourcen an Bord erschöpft sein und diese Ressourcen sind im Wesentlichen das Kaltgas, das ist Stickstoffgas,
zur äh Ausrichtung des Satelliten benutzt wird und wenn das erschöpft ist, dann können wir äh Gaja nicht mehr äh hat in den Messbetrieb halten
die sozusagen die das Abscannen des Himmels da nicht mehr funktioniert und die Messung mit Hilfe der äh lichtempfindlichen Detektoren nicht mehr geht. Äh das heißt also dann ist alles äh,
aber das bedeutet, dass wir dann weit über zehn Jahre gemessen haben werden.
Genau und da hat man in der letzten Sendung schon drauf hingewiesen, dass das ja sehr wünschens äh wert ist und wenn man ja auch gleich noch mal drüber ein bisschen sprechen, warum das so wünschenswert.
War und ist. Ja, das heißt.
Das dauert jetzt quasi nochmal drei ähzweieinhalb Jahre so maximal. Dann wird aber vermutlich das letzte bisschen Sprit, was drin ist, nochmal benutzt, um das Ding nochmal irgendwo hinzuschieben.
Ja, also man äh plant dann äh Gaja in einen stabilen Ort mit um die Sonne herumzuführen. Es ist so, dass äh dass ja der
Bereich, in dem Gaja arbeitet. Dieser zwei zwar ein stabiler Punkt ist, also da man braucht nur ganz wenig
Treibstoff, um ihn da zu halten, aber eben ein instabiler. Man braucht also äh regelmäßige, auch kleine Bahnkorrekturen, um dort zu bleiben. Wenn wir also dann keine Bahnkorrektur mehr durchführen würden, dann würde Gaja in irgendeine Richtung entweder irgendwie in einem Orbit um die Sonne gehen oder sogar mit einer
von zehn bis 51 Prozent auf die Erde äh fallen. Was kein Großschaden verursachen würden, aber wir wollen eigentlich äh.
Gehört, dann eben äh die Mission auch äh sinnvoll verhindern.
Genau. Ja ja. Ist ja dieser Langrangepunkt zwei äh äh ich meine ist ja ein bisschen voll geworden jetzt, ne? Da also jetzt dieser James Web auch noch mit dazugekommen, da muss man ein bisschen Platz machen.
Na ja, da ist super viel Platz. Tatsächlich ist es so, dass Gaja ja in einem Orbit um diesen Lakranzpunkt ist, der ihn bis zu 350.000 Kilometer
wegführt und ganz ähnlich ist es beim James Bab Teleskop, das ist eine andere Art von Orbit, das ist äh weil Gaja sogenannter Orbit bei James Web, ein Halo Orbit
und äh die sehen sich übrigens manchmal. Wir haben also jetzt äh schon.
Glaube zweimal, ich bin nicht ganz sicher, ob's noch ein drittes Mal war. Äh James Web mit Gaya aufgenommen. Da haben wir auch eine kleine Story damals draus gemacht und.
Wir sehen's nur als Punkt dann ne? Also man darf sich richtig groß was vorstellen aber da ist super viel Platz also es ist im ertnahen Raum natürlich viel viel ähm äh enger und auch der geostationäre Orbit ist viel viel.
Enger und während da oben ist wirklich viel Platz und so ein Raumschiff hat ja nur ein paar Meter Durchmesser und und äh hier reden wir wirklich von hunderttausenden von Kilometern, äh die wir um den Lagrenzpunkt auf ganz verschiedenen Bahnen
uns bewegen, das heißt die äh
da kann man noch viele äh schöne Weltraum-Opservatorium äh hinbringen. Es war ja auch schon in der Vergangenheit so, dass dank äh ähm gewesen sind und dass der Map äh
die Sonne auch zur Vermessung vom vom kosmischen Hintergrundstrahlung sowie Plank. Äh das sind also schon Objekte dort gewesen. Es ist ein sehr populärer Punkt natürlich.
Man dort äh den Vorteil hat, dass man da erstmal weit weg von der Erde stabile äh.
Situation dort und man hat nicht ständig die Erde im Vordergrund, zum Beispiel beim Hvel Space Teleskop ist ja so, man hat äh äh den Großteil der Zeit, die Erde in der Richtung, wo man eigentlich vielleicht gerade hingucken wollte, äh das ist also.
Und die Umlaufbahn ist alle 90 Minuten, kommt die Erde definitiv äh in den meisten Bereichen des Himmels ins Gesichtsfeld. Das heißt, man kann.
Viel längere und viele äh kontinuierlichere Beobachtungen vom Lagrangepunkt aus durchführen.
Kann James Web auch Geier sehen oder.
Ja, theoretisch ja, äh das war auch schon mal so eine Idee. Hätten wir gerne, dass sie uns nicht vielleicht da ja mal angucken. Äh das wäre auch eine witzige Sache. Muss man mal gucken, ob das klappt. Ich weiß nicht, wie da die Verhandlungen sind.
Einen größeren Spiegel, könnte schon ein bisschen mehr Detail bei rauskommen, oder? Das stimmt. Mhm. Interessant.
Genau. Ja, also dieser ähm Punkt ist sehr beliebt, eben einfach, um das All in Ruhe beobachten zu können und das ist ja das, was Gaja macht, ne. Gaja ist ein.
Sternenscanner, kann man im Prinzip sagen
der die ganze Zeit vor sich hin äh rotiert und schön scheibchenweise alles zusammenträgt und diese zehn Jahre Laufzeit, die man jetzt eben theoretisch und wie es aussieht auch praktisch äh erreicht. Wir haben einfach den Vorteil, während eben,
Die Raumsunde um die Sonne mit der Erde, um die Sonne herum äh zieht. Ja immer wieder neue Positionen einem, permanent und dann eben für einen Umlauf.
Ein Jahr braucht, hätte man dann sozusagen zehn Umläufe und kann alles nochmal aus derselben Position bis zu zehn Mal.
Sehen.
Genau, man kann aus derselben Position heraus ungefähr, aber wichtig ist natürlich auch die Sterne bewegen sich ja am Himmel und der der Punkt ist natürlich, wenn wir fünf Jahre messen, dann ist die Bewegung während dieser fünf Jahre
kleiner als bei ähzehn Jahren und das hat den großen Vorteil, dass die Westgenauigkeit zum Beispiel mit der wir die Bewegung der Sterne messen können bei zehn Jahren deutlich höher ist,
dass die Genauigkeitsverbesserung also äh erheblich ist. Also.
Insbesondere so langsamer die sich bewegen im Verhältnis.
Um um es mal ins Verhältnis zu setzen,
zwischen dem Gaja-DR zwei, über den wir geredet haben, auf unserem letzten Podcast, der im April 2018 veröffentlicht wurde, da
man Daten gehabt aus 22 Monaten und jetzt äh der neuste Katalog, der am 13. Juni veröffentlicht beziehungsweise der Vorkater teilweise, dass der Katalog schon im Dezember.
220 veröffentlicht, kommt aus 34 Monaten. Das ist ja gar nicht so viel mehr, aber die Genauigkeit, mit der wir die Bewegungen messen können, hat sich dadurch schon verdoppelt.
Bei einer Zehnjahresmission ist das so, dass das.
Also ein sechs oder sieben Mal genauer ist, äh dann die die mit der wir die Genauigkeit, mit der wir die Bewegung messen können. Und das ist etwas, was äh gerade die Leute, die sich mit der
Vigo von Sternen unserer Milchstraße zum Beispiel beschäftigen, also ein eine großen Fortschritt bringen wird, wenn wir dann irgendwann mal die zehn Jahre,
Daten auch äh zusammen haben, aber schon wenn wir beim nächsten Sternkatalog dann bei fünf Jahren
Messzeit, also sogar etwas mehr äh Veröffentlichung haben, dann wird die Genauigkeit deutlich zunehmen. Also das ist ein großer Vorteil, aber auch die anderen Daten, die Positionen der Sterne wird natürlich genauer und
was natürlich bei
besonders wichtig ist, die Entfernungsmessung würden auch genauer, mit je mehr Daten man hat, aber deren Genauigkeit steigt nicht ganz so schnell wie die Genauigkeit der Bewegungsmessung.
Und sieht man auch mehr Sterne dadurch.
Ähm Jein, man kann ein paar mehr Sterne sehen am schwachen Ende, weil die eben öfter mal beobachtet werden. Man hat äh es ist ja so, dass Gaja ein an.
Äh des Satelliten eine äh Intelligenz hat, die eben die äh Helligkeit der Sterne misst und wir schneiden sozusagen ganz bewusst ab.
Wir Sterne, die Lichtschwächer sind als das, was man 21ste Größenklasse nennt. Das entspricht ungefähr so einer Kerze in 20.000 Kilometer Entfernung.
Dass man die Sterne, die schlicht schwächer sind, nicht zum Erdboden funkt.
Das heißt, äh das hat damit zu tun, weil wir uns die Datenrate äh müssen wir für die Sterne äh haben und äh wir können nicht alle Messungen herunterladen. Das das schaffen wir halt einfach nicht zur Erde zu fu.
Weil die Bandbreite nicht aus.
Nicht ausreicht. Das ist so, dass wir nur mit etwa äh ja bis zu acht Megabit pro Sekunde äh über
typischerweise täglich 6 bis acht Stunden, daten zur Erde funken und sechs
bis acht Meter bitte, das weiß jeder, der selber ein Internetanschluss hat, das ist ähm na ja, in manchen Gegenden aufm Dorf schon sehr viel, aber in den meisten Gegenden doch eher schlecht und wenn wir da richtig viele Daten runterfunken können, ist das nicht so toll. Nur ist der Himmel ja im Wesentlichen leer. Das heißt,
Gaja ähm hat an Bord eine Messung, wo geguckt wird, wo sind eigentlich Sterne? Und nur diese Bereiche von den Messungen Messungen werden überhaupt zum
Boden gefunkt und da wird auch eine Helligkeitsgrenze gesetzt, äh um einfach dann genau mit dieser Datenrate das Optimum am Daten zum Boden zu funken.
Aber das finde ich ja jetzt dann doch ein bisschen überraschend muss ich sagen. Ich meine, sechs bis acht Megabit, das ist äh tatsächlich in etwa die Bitrate, mit der man so full HD Videos codiert.
Dreißig Bilder pro Sekunde da kommt man also kann man auch weniger Qualität machen, wenn man so brauchbare Qualität haben will am zu der Zeit so sechs bis acht Megabits so das was man eigentlich haben will.
Ist ja eigentlich schon eine ganze Menge an.
Ja, nur haben wir ja eine Gigabit-Kamera, ja? Ich meine, Gaja hat eine Gigabit-Kamera an Bord. Äh äh also wir haben eine Milliarde Pixel, das ist natürlich äh mehr als eine HD-Auflösung und.
Aber es muss ja nicht jedes Pixel auch übertragen werden.
Na ja, das müssen wir schon. Wir wollen jede Messung äh haben. Wir wir messen jede Sekunde ähm mehrere tausend Sterne.
Zum Boden gefunkt werden, indem da kleine Fenster ausgeschnitten werden, die dann zum Boden gefunkt werden. Und was noch hinzukommt, ist, dass wir nicht nur diese astrometrischen Messungen, also wo ist der Stern,
Messung an äh zum Boden funken, sondern auch noch Sternspektren haben und Spektren äh bedeutet ja, dass das Licht in die einzelnen Wellenlängen zerlegt wird und dadurch man relativ große Fenster braucht, weil man dann sozusagen ja das äh nicht mehr ein
Bild hat, was so punktförmig ist und ein bisschen was drumrum äh hat. Äh also so ein kleines Scheibchen, was was man von einem Stern natürlich als Bild auf der Fokalebene hat,
Man hat ein Spektrum, was eine gewisse Ausdehnung hat und äh und das muss dann natürlich auch alles zum Boden gefunden werden. Also die Hälfte zum Beispiel der Datenrate geht für
Spektrographen, den wir für die äh für zwei Dinge benutzen, nämlich für die Frage, wie schnell fliegt der Stern auf uns zu oder von uns weg mit Hilfe des Dopplereffekt.
Äh Geschwindigkeit auf uns zu oder von uns wegmisst äh ähm messen.
Und und außerdem werden mit diesen Spektren natürlich ja bestimmt chemische Zusammensetzung auf der Sternoberfläche, äh das sind auch Dinge, die da.
Eine Rolle spielen und die jetzt übrigens auch.
Teil äh zum ersten Mal jetzt mitveröffentlicht wurden bei unserem neuen Sternkatalog. Also da geht die Hälfte der Datenrate ungefähr drauf. Also ähm nein, man muss wirklich jede Messung.
Auf jedem der CCDs gleichzeitig zum Boden funken und äh das ist einfach äh mit mit der Datenrate, da geht's schon.
Datenkompression mit ein, die allerdings natürlich verlustfrei sein soll, damit es auch äh wissenschaftlich korrekte Daten sind.
Mhm. Was was für ein Frequenzbereich äh wird da genutzt für den Funk? Ist das äh das S-Bahnd oder äh was ist das für eine.
Frage. Ich da müsste ich glatt nachgucken, ob's das XS oder X-Band ist oder ja.
Aha. Also äh es ist natürlich klar, über so eine große Distanz kann man jetzt nicht beliebig mit normaler Funktechnik, also irgendwo ist dann ja auch äh Ende, das kann man ja irgendwie.
Da ist noch eine Einschränkung. Warum eigentlich die Antennen vielleicht nicht noch mehr Datenrate machen könnten, liegt auch daran
ja ähm einen ganz störungsfreien Betrieb haben muss und in dem es.
Rotiert und dass da zum Beispiel sich keine Veränderung dessen, was physikalisch das Trägheitsmoment ist, äh sein sollte und wenn wir zum Beispiel jetzt eine Parabolantenne hätten, die jetzt äh auf die Erde ausgerichtet ist, dann würden wir auch eine höhere Datenrate erzeugen können
Nur äh.
Die würde muss man schwenken können und das bedeutet natürlich, dass äh Satellit sich bei der Drehung dann völlig anders verhält und dadurch die Messung gestört wurden. Das.
Kann keinen Richtfunk machen.
Genau, das was man hat, das ist eine Antenne, die äh phasengesteuert sind. Das sind solche Phasen, gesteuerten Antennen, wodurch die Veränderung der äh Phase auf dem einzelnen ähm äh
äh kleinen Miniantennen sozusagen die Richtung, in der die.
Gesteuerte Interferenzen.
Die charakteristik äh in der man sozusagen sendet und empfängt äh dann festgelegt wird dadurch. Das.
Also etwas, was auch viele andere äh Raumschiffe haben, aber äh hier ist es ganz besonders wichtig, dass das eben rein elektronisch geht ohne eine Veränderung der Mechanik.
Mhm. So wie so eine Darling-Antenne auch funktioniert. Das ist ja heutzutage auch nicht im eigentlichen Sinne mehr eine Schüssel, sondern funktioniert nach dem selben.
Aber wir sind eben auch anderthalb Millionen Kilometer.
Ja ja klar, es ist nicht.
Ganz nah an der.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Ja, trotzdem habe ich mich gerade gefragt, ob
in Zukunft hier vielleicht Lasertechnologie zum Einsatz kommen könnte, um da mit höheren Datenraten zu arbeiten, weil das wäre ja dann im Prinzip, also das ist ja im Prinzip eine
Tierung, die jetzt gar nicht so die Raumsonde ist, sondern nur die Kommunikation in Anführungsstrichen. Hätte man jetzt so eine laserbasierte Kommunikation, sagen wir mal, man könnte dieses Gigabit auch wirklich roh äh zurückstrahlen, dann würdest du sagen, nehme ich.
Natürlich, wir würden alles nehmen, weil auch der Bereich dazwischen natürlich interessante Daten enthält, aber
in diesem Fall bei Gaia leider Prioritäten setzen und äh ich denke mal, ich bin jetzt äh von der Technik her nicht so bewandert, aber ich denke, solche Leser Dinge, äh solche Leserkommunikation könnten sicherlich helfen
oder man könnte rein theoretisch auch ein in der Nähe von einem Satelliten oder einer Raumsonde
ein Relaisatelliten äh postieren, zu dem dann die Daten übertragen werden und der dann mit einer höheren.
Das auch äh weitergeben könnte. Das sind alles Dinge, die aber eine solche Mission verteuern und wie bei jeder Raumfahrtenmission wird man immer ganz genau hingucken und sagen äh man muss auch die letzten drei, vier Prozent da noch einsparen äh.
Dann zu sagen, wir kriegen dieses Projekt auch wirklich genehmigt.
Hat immerhin den Vorteil, gegenüber vielen anderen Raumfahrtmission, dass wir voll im Budget geblieben sind, also etwas sensationelles, was bei Raumfahrtprojekten nicht zum Alltag.
Von James Web zum Beispiel wissen.
Wie gesagt das das ist auch ein Punkt warum Gaja eigentlich einen sehr guten Ruf hat weil das auch alles
sozusagen innerhalb der Prognose da war. Aber wie gesagt natürlich die Wunschträume für eine solche Mission werden immer
ein größeres Gerät noch zu haben, was noch äh mehr Photonen liefert, äh eine andere Kommunikation, wie wir sie eben angesprochen haben und.
Ja vieles mehr also da die Wunschträume sind immer größer als das was man dann genehmigt aber wir sind im Prinzip sehr sehr zufrieden mit dem was Gaia leistet.
Wollte eigentlich erst so gegen Ende mal so neue Missionsideen äh reden, aber bleiben wir vielleicht noch mal kurz dabei. Ich fand das nämlich jetzt gerade eine interessante äh Variante, so diese Abwägung, okay, man könnte ja im Prinzip nochmal für die Satelliten, Satelliten bauen
der dann.
Ohne weitere Probleme so eine Parabolantäne, die dann auch so richtig groß sein könnte, um dann einfach noch mit äh traditioneller nicht lichtbasierter Kommunikation ähm einfach eine höhere Datenrate machen kann und dann muss
der Satellit sozusagen nur noch.
Um die Ecke äh Funken. Hat aber natürlich dann auch diesen Faktor mit drin. Was ist, wenn der dann kaputt geht? Weil das ist ja dann sozusagen noch mal ein zweites Teil, was genauso feingesteuert und genauso fein überwacht werden muss und präzise gebaut werden muss.
Völlig richtig und äh und ich meine jede Komplexitätserhöhung äh erhöht auch Risiken. Das muss man sich natürlich immer bewusst sein. Das.
Klar. Aber wenn Raumfahrten natürlich in Zukunft vielleicht mal billiger wird und Nutzlasten weiter dann kann man trotzdem natürlich vielleicht auch solche Dinge mehr.
Am Denken als als bisher. Meine Gaja ist mit einer russischen Sojus-Rakete von ausgestartet und äh weil es einfach billiger war. Eine Ariane fünf war
sozusagen zu teuer, deshalb ähm war ursprünglich mal die Ideenariane fünf zu nehmen,
äh um Gaja durchzukriegen, musste man eine gewisse Reduktion der Größe machen, um's dann in eine Sojus packen zu können und heute wissen wir können wir nicht mehr benutzen aus politischen Gründen, da sind wir also heilfroh, dass das 2013 noch nicht so das äh Problem war.
Man sieht, dass da eben auch Politik noch eine Rolle spielen.
Mhm. Ja andererseits durch dieses neue von SpaceX. Wenn das äh dann mal an Start kommt, sieht ja so schlecht nicht aus. Wäre natürlich dann auch ganz andere Satellitengrößen auf einmal denk.
Da könnte vielleicht solche Raketen von SpaceX mal was für die Astronomen und nicht gegen die Astronomen tun, was denn wissen sie ja, dass die Astronomen nicht gerade sehr äh happy darüber sind.
Ja, das äh ist natürlich nochmal so ein anderer Aspekt. Ja, okay. Ähm gut. Also äh.
Wird zehn Jahre laufen, gehen wir mal einfach mal von aus, also sieht zumindest sehr gut aus, dass das sowohl politisch als auch technisch abgesichert ist.
Und ja, wahrscheinlich können wir dann hier so in fünfzehn
äh also 15 Jahre nach Staat irgendwann mal den finalen Katalog beleuchten und äh darüber realisieren, was denn alles schon
Neues herausgekommen ist, aber wir wollen auf jeden Fall mal so einen kleinen Zwischenstand aufnehmen. Ähm ich habe mir auch so ein paar Sachen aus der letzten Sendung noch äh notiert, wo es immer so hieß, muss man mal gucken und so.
Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei der äh Technik und hast es ja vorhin auch schon angesprochen. Es muss ja immer in dieser Kalibration gearbeitet werden. Also inwiefern ist das.
Was hatte das für einen Erfolg, wenn wenn es einen hatte? Und gab's denn überhaupt noch Probleme mit der Raumsonde, als als solche.
Ja
Also wir haben tatsächlich Probleme mit der Raumsonde gehabt äh äh die wir teilweise wirklich lösen konnten und teilweise welche, die uns immer noch beschäftigen werden und eine größere Gruppen vom äh unserem in unserem Gajaprojekt eben immer noch,
deren Gehirnschmalz erfordern, um,
nur sozusagen mehr Daten zu gewinnen im Laufe der Zeit, sondern diese Daten auch immer noch besser zu verstehen. Also um mal drei Dinge zu sagen, weil die bei Gaja ein Problem waren.
Am Anfang der Mission war es so, dass wir innerhalb kürzester Zeit sagen, dass die die Empfindlichkeit der Instrumente innerhalb von Wochen runtergingen.
Äh wir haben das dann äh unsere die Hypothese, die auf die einzige mögliche ist, ist, dass sich dort Wasser
in Form von Eis auf den Instrumenten abgesetzt hat und äh zum Glück haben wir an Bord Heiz
Elemente, die dieses Wasser wieder beseitigen können und schon auf dem Weg zum L2 hat ja Gaja so auch bewusst solche Heizelemente eingeschaltet.
Dann dafür sorgen, dass jedes Wasser, was vielleicht noch ähm,
nach dem Staat vorhanden war aus dem wissenschaftlichen Instrument vertrieben wird. Heiz muss man sich übrigens vorstellen, dass das jetzt nicht auf 100 Grad geheizt wird, sondern äh die Vokalebene ist hat - 100 Grad etwa, wo wir Messungen machen und mal Hals etwa auf - 50 Grad auf. Das reicht dann auch, um sowas dann wieder
beseitigen im.
Fünfzig Grad.
Ja minus fünfzig Grad, das nennen wir dann Heizen, also,
Genau, das ist.
Immer noch unter dem Gefrierpunkt, also.
Aber wir sind im Weltall, wo es wo wir ein Vakuum haben und das heißt äh dass die das erreicht, dass dass es denn auch das äh ähm Eis dann langsam verschwindet im Laufe der Zeit. Also das ist das ist äh nicht die wie die Verhältnisse auf der Erde sind, aber.
Ähm also es ist.
Hitze letzten Endes Bewegung von Atomen ist.
Genau, genau. Das heißt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit äh er wird auf jeden Fall erhöht, dass es dann sich sozusagen wieder äh in den Weltraum oder ins Baku, um aus den äh.
Also es bleibt Eis, aber es löst sich ab.
Genau und kommt dann irgendwann aus den beiden Öffnungen von dem Gaya Instrument heraus. Nur hat sich das dann auch immer wieder äh sozusagen festgesetzt und wir haben innerhalb von.
Monaten bis Jahren dann immer wieder auch äh das Problem gehabt, äh woher die wo die Quelle ist, äh das haben wir bis heute nicht rausgekriegt. Das muss eigentlich aus dem.
Servicemodul, was eigentlich abgetrennt sein sollte von den wissenschaftlichen Instrumenten gekommen sein. Da gab's nämlich keine klaren Vorschriften, wie viel Wasser da drin sein sollte, weil es ja abgetrennt ist.
Aber irgendwo muss es herkommen, ne? Also,
dass es einen Punkt gewesen, nur jetzt haben wir die glückliche Situation, dass wir jetzt wirklich festgestellt haben, nach der letzten Aufheizen, ich habe jetzt nicht mehr im Kopf, wie lange das her ist, aber es ist schon Jahre jetzt her, äh hat ist nichts mehr passiert und wir sehen ein ganz, ganz langsam.
Effekt noch immer, aber der ist äh da können wir extra polieren bis zum Ende der Mission, dass das alles im Rahmen bleibt. Das heißt, wir brauchen keine einzige,
Aufheizaktion wir machen an der Stelle,
ist etwas sehr schönes, weil bei jedem Aufheizen nämlich auch die thermische Stabilität des Satelliten, die natürlich für unsere hochpräzisen Messungen äh enorm wichtig sind äh ja, dass die erhalten bleibt und man nicht wieder sozusagen abwarten muss, bis wir wieder stabil sind.
Haben wir Streulichtprobleme, das ist auch etwas, was mit wir leben können. Wir haben ein bisschen mehr Hintergrundlicht.
In dem Satelliten als als wir mal gewollt haben aber da das reduziert die Genauigkeit nur um einen Effekt den mit dem wir gut leben können aber ein wichtiger Effekt ist dass die.
Wir ja zwei Teleskope haben, die in zwei verschiedenen Richtungen im Himmel gucken, nämlich hundertsechseinhalb Grad in zwei verschiedene Richtungen am Himmel und der Winkel zwischen diesen beiden Richtungen, der muss sehr, sehr genau bekannt sein oder möglichst auch stabil sein und.
Ist äh deutlich instabiler als wir es von sozusagen ursprünglich gewollt haben und wackelt ein bisschen hin und her,
und äh dieses wird zwar mit einem bestimmten Instrument vermessen, aber nur an zwei Punkten des Spiegels,
und äh können wir also in gewissen Grenzen berücksichtigen. Damit können wir 97Prozent dieses Effektes sozusagen wieder herausrechnen.
Aber wenn man sie genau hinguckt, dann sind da Effekte, die noch davon abhängen, wo in der Fokalebene man genau ist, das heißt, solche Abhängigkeiten, die muss man dann durch die genaue Untersuchung der Daten und durch,
mathematische Modellierung herausbekommen, indem man die Daten selber benutzt, um solche äh Effekte dann noch noch weiter zu verbessern und.
Da arbeiten wirklich Gruppen dran, die,
Daten verbessern und das hat jetzt auch schon einen Erfolg gehabt beim dritten Sternkatalog, dass da Verbesserungen sind. Aber da sind wir immer noch nicht ganz zufrieden. Wir wollen da auch noch nach wie vor diese
systematischen Fehler, die dadurch hineinkommen äh verringern und das wird auch bestimmt noch äh weitergehen, aber das sind Dinge
vom Staat in der Weise nicht vorhergesehen haben. Es gibt immer unvorhergesehene Dinge. Wir sind eigentlich froh, dass Gaja super arbeitet, aber ein paar Dinge hätten wir uns vielleicht auch gerne erspart. Äh.
Die Sache sehr komplex macht.
Ist das ein Konstruktionsfehler oder wodurch kommt dieses Wackeln.
Ja, es hat letztendlich mit thermischen Dingen zu tun. Eigentlich sollte Teleskope weitgehend thermisch entkoppelt sein von dem äh Raumschiff selber, von der Umhüllung.
Das heißt, wenn wir uns mit dem Satelliten, wenn der sich dreht, äh verändert sich das schon und außerdem auch mit der Entfernung zu Sonne, die Entfernung.
Zur Sonne von der Erde zum Beispiel ändert sich ja im Laufe eines Jahres und dann sehen wir auch, dass die Amplitude dieses Effektes mit der im jahreszeitlichen Lauf sozusagen sich auch verändert und da wird der Entfernung nicht Jahreszeiten, sondern Entfernung zur Sonne.
Da ist letztendlich thermische äh Übertragung drin, die eigentlich nicht sein sollte. Das ist, man kann es als Konstruktionsfehler bezeichnen, aber man hat.
Damals nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen gedacht, man hätte das.
Fehler ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben gesagt, aber konstruktionsbedingt.
Na ja, man würde sagen, äh bei der nächsten Mission muss man drauf achten und aus diesem Fehler lernen.
Ja, mhm. Abstand zur Sonne, ich meine, der ist ja im Prinzip mehr oder weniger konstant, nur dass wir eben diese Elypse der der Umlaufbahn der Erde haben, also der Unterschied macht schon Wasser aus.
Im Januar ein bisschen näher an der Sonne als im Juli. Also das dieser das kann man auch sehen an den Daten. Äh das heißt wir können den Abstand so ein bisschen sozusagen auch in der in der Amplitude dieser Variation sehen. Und da wie gesagt.
Januar sind wir näher.
Ja am 6. Januar glaube ich ist der ja genau, jetzt kommt diejenigen, die ich weiß, dass du weißt, wie die Jahreszeiten wirklich entstehen und äh
aber es dieses äh es gibt bestimmt Leute, die dieses äh Konzept im im Kopf haben.
Irgendeine passende Verschwörung.
Nee, aber aber auf jeden Fall ist das etwas, was eine der Hauptpunkte ist, die immer noch äh zu verbessern sind und wo aber die Hoffnung besteht, dass wir diese Effekte immer noch besser im Griff haben und dann,
auch so um ganz äh elementare Dinge wie die Abbildung von dem Teleskop äh da die die äh erzeugt ja eine ganz bestimmte Art von Bildern und.
Die ist auch noch davon abhängig welche Farbe und welche Spektren die Sterne haben und also das was man die nennt also für die.
Aussieht, da gibt's auch immer noch Verbesserungen an an Dingen, die da gemacht werden oder wie man die Daten dann weiterverarbeitet. Da gibt's immer auch noch Optimierungsdinge, also.
Am Ende ist es so, dass es äh immer nur dass man die Gajadaten selber ja benutzen muss, um das Instrument auch weiter zu vermessen. Das heißt, wir messen nicht nur für die
mehrere Milliarden Sterne die wir verbessern also fast zwei Milliarden Sterne für die wir jetzt.
Einen guten Katalog äh erstellt haben. Äh die Daten, sondern wir benutzen die gleichen Daten auch, um das Instrument äh besser kennenzulernen und das wird, wie gesagt, immer.
Auch durch bessere mathematische Verfahren, bessere Überlegungen, die Phänomene zu verstehen. Äh am Ende zu einem besseren Sternkatalog.
Wir hatten das glaube ich letztes Mal auch schon tangiert. Das ist ja so bestimmt, ich erinnere mich jetzt gerade nicht mehr ganz genau, was es war, aber so bestimmte äh Dinge gibt, an denen man sich quasi, also.
Wo man Gewissheit hat, äh an denen man dann sozusagen die Genauigkeit des äh des Instruments wiederum kalibrieren kann.
Ja, also eine eine der Hilfen sind da die Quasare. Es ist ja so, dass die Quasare, das sind äh ähm ja Kerne von Gala Kern,
ein schwarzes Loch in der äh im Zentrum ist, wo und wo durch das Hineinfließen der Materie dort äh Energie in Richtung in zum Beispiel manchmal zur Erde gesandt wird und die dann sehr hell leuchten und die sind so weit entfernt, dass sie selbst für Galia natürlich,
keine Bewegung haben und auch keine Veränderung durch die Bewegung der Raumsonde um die Sonne, also keine Paralaxe.
Das hilft auf jeden Fall auch zur Kalibration, weil nämlich diese Bewegung, diese äh Variationen des ähm
Basiswinkels äh das fischen den beiden Teleskopen äh sozusagen zu einer einer Unsicherheit in dem Nullpunkt der Paralaxe. Das ist das, was wir für die Entfernungsmessung benutzen führt und äh
Diese Sache wird also immer besser auch korrigiert. Also da da kann man auch zum Beispiel äh benutzen äh.
Ganz schlaue Ideen, äh das das das, was man misst am Ende äh für diesen Paralaxen-Nullpunkt.
Zum Beispiel auch von der Farbe der Sterne abhängt, aber da gibt es zum Beispiel ja Doppelsterne, bei denen beide Komponenten praktisch in der gleichen Entfernung sind und allein die Tatsache, dass sie in der gleichen Entfernung sind, kann man erlaubt es einem sozusagen die Effekte der
unterschiedlichen Farbgebung mit zu berücksichtigen.
Unterschiedlichen Farbgebung der beiden Sterne.
Weil die ja die gleiche Entfernung haben müssen am Ende, ne? Wenn man diese Randbedingungen für ganz viele Objekte nimmt und die auch gut vermessen sind,
dann kann man solche ähm sozusagen Verschiebungen aufgrund der Farbe äh zum Beispiel mit heraus korrigieren
also man muss sich nur sozusagen Dinge überlegen, wo man nicht allzu viele Annahmen über die Objekte reinbringen wollen, denn wir wollen ja gerade mit Gaja relativ unabhängig von irgendwelchen Annahmen über die Objekte sein, damit wir eine objektive Messung zum Beispiel Entfernung und,
Sterne habt oder auch der Helligkeit und vieles andere mehr. Äh und äh um da sollte man kann man also nicht
zu viele Annahmen reinstecken, aber eine solche Annahmen, dass mittlerweile dergleichen Entfernung praktisch sind, das ist eine, die man auf jeden Fall machen kann und also solche Art von.
Analysen, die man dann für für unter ähm äh Stichproben von dem
von dem von den Gaja Daten macht, die helfen einem am Ende die Daten immer besser zu verstehen.
So, jetzt gab es das schon angesprochene neue äh Release. Genau genommen gab es ja zwei. Es gab einen early Data Release drei und dann das eigentliche Data Release
drei ähm Olli war jetzt genau vor zwei Jahren tatsächlich.
Fast auf den Tag genau. Heute ist der zweite Dezember zweiundzwanzig, es war am 3 Dezember 20 und das Data Release, was nicht early war, das kam dann ähm.
Jetzt am dreizehnten Juni zweiundzwanzig heraus. Was war.
Der Grund dafür, dass so noch mal aufzuteilen, war das von vornherein so geplant oder äh hat man sich das später erst überlegt und ähm was.
Ist nun sozusagen drin, also vielleicht noch mal kurz erläutern, also Data Release, klar, das ist also die Veröffentlichung äh der Daten und das ist sozusagen das, was eben.
Sozusagen das Ergebnis eigentlich dieser Mission. Darum darum geht's, geht um diesen Katalog
aller Sterne, die man irgendwie sehen kann, plus noch ein paar andere äh Objekte. Man schaut sich halt einfach alles intensiv an. Es wird die ganze Zeit gescannt und dadurch, dass wir jetzt immer mehr Beobachtungen haben der Sterne aus allen möglichen Positionen.
Wird immer alles genauer und ist man sich immer sicher und kann vielleicht auch was vorher mal ein Konflikt war, weiter äh auflösen, umso länger das Ding läuft, umso mehr fällt dabei raus. Was.
Ist nun drin im DR drei.
Also diese Datum-Releases, das ist ja das, wovon die Astronomen immer hoffen, dass es möglichst schnell kommt,
dann die Daten, Geier Daten benutzen können. Sobald wir die sozusagen einspeisen in unsere Tatenbanken, dann dann sieht man sofort, dass da hunderte und tausende Astronomen sofort rangehen, um die Daten herunterzuladen, um dann daraus Wissenschaft zu machen
Aber es ist natürlich wichtig, dass da jetzt was Neues dazukommt. Wir haben ja beim letzten Mal über den zwei geredet und das war schon mal ein Riesenschritt. Da sind wir denn bei.
Eins Komma vier, eins Komma 5 Milliarden Sternen gewesen und für 1,3 von denen hat man dann auch Entfernungsmessungen, Bewegung der Sterne gemessen und.
Die Helligkeiten und das war also ein Riesenschritt gegenüber dem, was man vorher hatte. Jetzt äh haben wir vielleicht einen nicht ganz so großen Schritt, aber
also äh jetzt ähm 1,8 Milliarden Sterne, von denen 1,5 Milliarden Sterne diese wichtigen Daten enthalten
und haben dabei natürlich eine Verbesserung der Genauigkeit zum Beispiel der Paralaxen, der Entfernungsmessung und der Bewegung der Sterne mit drin. Das ist also die Astrometrie
und äh zusätzlich äh hat man auch natürlich die Messung der Helligkeit und der groben Messung der Farben,
hat man im Data Release im Early Data Release drei im Dezember 2020 veröffentlicht
Und warum man das gemacht hat, hat ein bisschen damit zu tun, dass natürlich die Astronom möglichst schnell an die Daten herankommen. Und der Punkt ist, dass viele von den anderen Produkten, die wir in Gaya haben,
die Astrometrie brauchen, die also den sozusagen den den Teil, der eigentlich dann schon fertig war im äh Dezember zweitausendzwanzig.
Den sie benutzen, um da die weiteren Produkte, die wir jetzt im 13. Juni 22 veröffentlicht haben, in dem eigentlichen Dart Data Release, dass man dass die die verwendet haben, aber warum
sollte man dann den Astronomen nicht ein bisschen früher schon diese Daten, die ja
wissenschaftliche Daten sind zur Verfügung stellen und das hat den Vorteil, dass dann eben auch äh
die Leute nicht ungeduldig auf den nächsten warten, sondern schon mal äh wieder zwei Jahre damit an Wissenschaft machen können und dieser Release drei war insofern auch sehr erfolgreich. Da steckt also sozusagen die Grundastrometrie von Einzelsternen
drin für äh in diesem Fall eins Kommafünf, 1,8 Milliarden Sterne, je nachdem, ob man äh die Positionsmessung hat man für eins Komma acht Milliarden Sterne für eins Komma5
man auch diese anderen Daten, die Astronomen brauchen und die Helligkeits- und äh Farbmessung. Die wurden also veröffentlicht in dem drei und jetzt im Juni 2013 kamen jetzt wichtige neue Produkte dazu.
Und zwar ähm erstmal von der von der Art der Daten äh wurden erstmals auch Spektren veröffentlicht und zwar zwei Typen von
Spektren, nämlich äh niedrig aufgelöste Spektren, wo man also die Energieverteilung der Sterne über die einzelnen Wellenlängen.
Sozusagen grob bestimmen kann, grob heißt, dass man sagen wir mal ja.
Sieht, wie die wie die Form dieser Energieverteilung und Abhängigkeit von der Wellenlänge ist, aber man sieht eben nur in Einzelfällen zum Beispiel einzelne Spektralinien, die einem Astronomen ja etwas zum Beispiel die chemische Zusammensetzung sagen.
Diese bisher war es so, dass wir ähm das sind zwei Fotometer, wie wir sie nennen, die eigentlich Spektrographen sind
äh wir bisher benutzt haben, um daraus Helligkeit im Blauen in einem roten zu messen, indem wir einfach die Photonen zusammengezählt haben, die aus den beiden Spektografen gekommen sind. Okay, ganz so einfach ist es im Ende nicht, aber so grob.
Ist die Idee davon und daraus eine Farbe bestimmt haben. Aber jetzt dadurch, dass wir viel mehr sozusagen kleine Bints dieser äh Spektren haben, können wir sozusagen die Farben genauer bestimmen, indem wir sagen, wir wollen jetzt
nur wissen, wie viel Licht, sagen wir mal, von 3tausend bis äh fünftausend.
Oder 300 bis 500 Nanometer, äh wie viel Licht aus diesem Bereich kommt bei einem Stern und aus dem Restbereich von dann,
fünfhundert bis zehntausend oder so, im roten Bereich, wie wir das nennen, sondern wir wollen auch detailliert wissen, wie viel, sagen wir mal, zwischen äh ja.
400 und 50 und
500 Nanometern kommen oder so. Also man kann das noch viel, viel kleiner äh sozusagen die Energieverteilung dann bestimmen und das ist natürlich nützlich für Astronomen, die Sterne
modellieren und die dann auch das äh die die äh Sterne genauer verstehen wollen. Äh das ist also etwas, was hier nützlich ist und auch für andere Dinge im Übrigen äh sehr nützlich ist. Zum Beispiel
Asteroiden und alles Mögliche wird das benutzt und dann gibt es diese.
Spektren von den Radialgeschwindigkeitsinstrument, von dem ich ganz kurz schon vorher sprach, was ja benutzt wird, indem man im nahen Infraroten in dem Fall.
Einen kleineren Spektralbereich hat, in dem man äh aber sehr deutliche Spektrallinien sehen kann. Das ist also so aufgelöst, dass man da die die Spektrallinien, die verursacht wurden durch die Absorption von chemischen,
Elementen von Atom und Molekülen in der Sternatmosphäre, die sie diese dunklen Linien machen, wie ja auch die Sonne sie macht und aus denen man dann,
einerseits was über die chemischen Häufigkeiten und über die Temperatur in der Sterneoberfläche und.
Die schwere Beschleunigung an der Oberfläche ist, also wie viel Gravitation da sozusagen ist. Das kann man alles aus den Spektren
aber das Wichtigste war für für die Astronomie erstmal die
Bewegung der Sterne auf uns zu oder von uns weg, aber das ist eben zwei Dinge, die die Chemie und äh die Sternparameter
und äh auf der anderen Seite diese Dinge. Das sind neue Produkte, die wir noch nie veröffentlicht haben. Wir haben vorher schon Radialgeschwindigkeiten veröffentlicht, aber nicht die Spektren, aus denen das sozusagen geschlossen wurde und,
das ist sind natürlich jetzt Dinge, die äh jetzt benutzt werden kann, um zum Beispiel etwas über die chemische.
Ähm Verteilung der Elemente bei Sternen innerhalb unserer Milchstraße äh eine Rolle spielen. Also das sind neue Produkte erstmal.
Dann gehören zum Data-Release drei neue Unterkataloge. Da haben wir zum Beispiel auch ähm jetzt erstmals Daten für eine größere Zahl von,
Doppelsterben, die da drin sind, weil Doppelsterne bewegen sich am Himmel anders als Einzelsterne
die beiden Komponenten und manchmal sieht man auch nur einen von den beiden Komponenten, wenn die eine zum Beispiel sehr lichtschwach ist oder sehr nah dran ist. Ähm
dass dass die also eine zusätzliche Bewegung machen, die laufen ja beide um einen gemeinsamen Schwerpunkt und das heißt die machen noch eine zusätzliche Wackelbewegung am Himmel und.
Die kann man jetzt benutzen um zum Beispiel auf Parameter zu schließen, die einem was über den Doppelsterncharakter.
Sagen und Doppelsterde sind enorm wichtig in der Astronomie, weil sie sozusagen zusätzliche Informationen bereitstellen.
Gar nicht so selten, ne.
Sind überhaupt nicht selten, also man kann eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass die Hälfte aller Sterne Mitglieder von Doppelsterben sind am Ende, also bei welchen Komponenten, die sehr weit auseinander sind
ist es auch gar nicht so wichtig, die bewegen sich im Prinzip fast wie ein Einzelstern, weil die Bewegung umeinander
tausende von Jahren, teilweise dauert oder und deshalb sozusagen zu vernachlässigen sein kann oder in so einem kurzen Messzeitraum gar nicht so wichtig sind, aber wenn sie näher zusammen sind.
Spielt das natürlich 'ne ganz große Rolle und also da haben also viele darauf gewartet, da es jetzt ein erster Katalog entstanden und äh der wird natürlich in den nächsten.
Den nächsten Sternkatalog noch wichtiger werden, weil je länger man misst, desto mehr kann man natürlich von dem Orbit auch sehen, äh wie wie die sich bewegen,
Das heißt, da hilft natürlich auch enorm, wenn wir dann am Ende zehn Jahre wirklich Messzeit haben gegenüber einer ursprünglich fünf Jahre Mission, also über Doppelsterne werden wir deutlich mehr lernen.
Haben wir einen neuen Katalog über verinnerliche Sterne. Auch da äh haben wir jetzt einen Katalog, der sehr viel größer ist.
Dann haben wir einen über die Radialgeschwindigkeiten, von denen ich eben schon sprach, dahaben wir jetzt
33 Millionen Sterne auch schon die äh Bewegung der Sterne auf uns zu oder von uns weggemessen. Also die eine weitere Komponente, die wir mit den Positionsmessungen von Gaja, äh wo es ja um Winkelmessungen geht, gar nicht äh mit
bekommen können. Beim DR zwei, bei dem Vorgängerkatalog waren's nur 7 Millionen Sterne, aber das waren für die Leute, die die Bewegung von Sternen in unser Galaxis
mit die wichtigsten Daten, diese 7 Millionen Faust von den einsKommadrei damals Milliarden und jetzt äh von denen sind diese 33 Millionen ein besonders wertvoller Datensatz und der wird natürlich auch noch viel größer im Laufe der äh Zeit
und weil man damit sozusagen dann alle Raumkomponenten der.
Haben kann. Und dann ist ein gibt's ein Ast ein Katalog über Asteroiden und äh auch Spektren von Asteroiden, die man gemessen hat.
Und äh dann gibt es einen Leute, die haben versucht oder uns nicht nur versucht, sondern auch natürlich schafft, aus den Daten
eine erste Klassifizierung der Sterne zu machen, also welche Sterntypen sind das, die Rohdaten? Was für ein Sterntyp ist das? Welche
Eigenschaften haben, die welche Temperaturen haben die Sterne, solche Parameter wurden dann auch bestimmt. Das kann man hinterher nochmal genauer machen, während sich die Sterne einzeln anguckt, aber sie geben schon eine gewisse Orientierung als,
als Datensatz, den wir dann sozusagen zur Verfügung stellen.
Überrascht mich jetzt so ein bisschen. Ich dachte, das wäre würde mehr oder weniger schon bei der normalen Beobachtung bei abfallen, wenn man irgendwie weiß, wo die Dinger sind und wie hell sie sind und dann wie weit.
Sind, dann ergibt sich ja dann im Prinzip auch automatisch eine Größe und eine Masse daraus und dann ist weiß man auch in etwa schon, was das ist oder.
Eine Massenbestimmung ist noch ganz schwierig bei Sternen. Also das ist äh äh also man muss dann dafür mal richtig Sternmodelle äh haben, die einem sagen, in welcher Entwicklungsphase ein Stern und welche
Masse hat und welche Temperatur und äh es spielen alle möglichen Dinge eine Rolle. Also die äh das ist das ist bei Doppelstern
Masse direkt bestimmen, wenn man alle Komponenten eines Doppelsterns, einschließlich der Radialgeschwindigkeiten äh zusätzlich hat, dann kann man daraus auch Massen bestimmen. Aber das ist sehr viel schwieriger
also diese Daten.
Das ist nur Sinn natürlich teilweise Standardtechniken ähm mit denen man das macht, aber da gibt es auch unterschiedlich gute Modelle, mit denen man zum Beispiel die
Parameter von Sternen bestimmt, aber äh das ist sozusagen ein Datensatz, der für einen großen Teil der Sterne eben auch solche Parameter ähm mitbestimmt
zumindest mit dem, was man innerhalb von einigen Monaten dann äh aus dem Datensatz machen kann. Wie gesagt, im Einzelfall äh können auch Astronomen ihre eigenen Modelle benutzen und da noch andere Erkenntnisse draus ziehen.
Ich würde gleich noch mal gerne auf die Beobachtung des Sonnensystems nochmal genauer äh kommen, aber das finde ich jetzt gerade interessant, weil ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen so ähm könnte vielleicht nochmal zum Verständnis.
Beitragen. Der Blick von Gaja auf die Sterne. Also vielleicht können wir das mal sozusagen sortieren.
In der Reihenfolge von was sind die Dinge, die man über jeden Stern.
Herausfindet und dann sozusagen absteigend mit der Anzahl der Sterne, für die man das bestimmen kann
sind dann sozusagen immer die ungenaueren äh Informationen. Also was wissen wir über jeden jedes Objekt.
Sieht.
Ja, also was wir mindestens haben, sind die Positionen zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt innerhalb des Messpunktes, wird's Bestzeitraums, also wo der Stern steht.
Kriegen wir sehr genau hin und sonst würden wir den Stern auch nicht aufnehmen. Also wenn wir wenn wir diese Größe nicht bestimmen, dann kommt er halt nicht in den Sternenkatalog. Wir haben natürlich Daten für mehr als die 1,8 Milliarden Sterne, die wir wirklich veröffentlicht haben. Aber wir äh haben.
Man das nicht immer, wenn man was sieht. Also ich meine, kann es sein, dass.
Ja ja, ja.
Und man weiß nicht wo es ist also.
Aber aber die die Genauigkeit ist der entscheidende Punkt. Also nur wenn es mit der Genauigkeit, die auch Gaja äh anstrebt, äh gemessen werden kann, dann dann bleibt es auch im Katalog drin. Also.
Aber wie messe ich denn die Genauigkeit? Also ich meine, ich sehe ja wohin, also man weiß doch verstehe ich es nicht.
Das kann man daran messen, wie gut die einzelnen, wir haben ja viele Messungen, die man im Laufe der Zeit, das hast du ja selber gesagt
äh macht und wenn die Messung am Ende zu einem guten fit führt, das ist eigentlich sowas wie kleinste Quadratefit, wie vielleicht der eine oder andere aus einer Regressions.
Machen kann. Da steckt im Prinzip was Ähnliches dahinter. Nur geht es hier um viel dimensionale äh die da gemacht werden und.
Und Gleichungssysteme, wo Millionen von Gleichungen eine Rolle spielen und Ähnliches, aber äh da geht es also darum, wie äh gut die Parameter am Ende sind. Das kann man bei den.
Aus der aus der Güte des Fitz kann man etwas über die Qualität der Daten sagen
Da gibt es natürlich Grenzen und es kommen auch durchaus äh Objekte hinein, bei denen der Fit vielleicht nicht so super war, aber man gibt dann auch an
Parameter äh da herausgekommen sind und wie genau die jeder Stern hat natürlich auch eine unterschiedliche
Genauigkeit, die man auch angeben kann wirklich. Man kann also aus dem aus dem mathematischen Lösung der
Sternposition aus diesen Fitz herausbekommen, wie gut kennen wir die Sternposition und da gibt es natürlich Daten, die
aus irgendeinem Grund völlig inkonsistent sind, weil da äh vielleicht sich Messungen gestört haben oder in Bereichen großer Sterndichte. Es ist
immer können sich Sachen überlappen, da da werden Dinge weggeschmissen sozusagen, also,
Wir haben paar 1hundert Millionen Sterne mehr als die 1,8 Milliarden Sterne, die äh die jetzt veröffentlicht worden sind. Aber die allermeisten sind tatsächlich veröffentlich.
Aber also was was im Katalog ist, da ist man sich bei der Position sicher ab an bestimmt.
In einem bestimmten Fehlerrahmen, den wir auch angeben, ganz genau. Und äh jetzt äh ist es so die nächsten äh.
Punkte sind, wo wir die während des Messzeitraums auch eine Veränderung der Position mit.
Einer hohen Genauigkeit äh sagen konnten. Und zwar gibt es ja zwei Dinge, die man an an der Veränderung der Position messen kann. Da ist einmal die Bewegung des Sternes selber am Himmel, weil der Stern sich eben im Raum bewegt.
Sieht man von der Erde eben, der läuft über einen bestimmten Bereich des Himmels. Das das nennt man Eigenbewegung. Das ist die eine Winkelmessung. Wie um wie viel
ja Millibogen Sekunden pro Jahr sich ein Stern am Himmel in den beiden Koordinaten nennt man das im Himmel, sowas wie Länge und Breite auf der Erde äh wie sich das verändert.
Gibt es aber natürlich die scheinbare Bewegung äh Wackelbewegung, die da rührt, dass wir ja mit Gaja um die Sonne laufen und dadurch unsere Beobachtungsposition ein bisschen ändern. Das ist ja das, was wir dann zur Entfernungsmessung.
Sonnensystem ja auch noch selber ab.
Genau, genau, durch das Sonnensystem bewegt. Das ist der andere Punkt. Und äh diese Bewegung dafür brauchen wir eben einen guten fit in den Parametern, die eben auch die Eigenbewegung und die Paralachse enthält
Das sind in 1,5 Milliarden beim DR 3 Katalog.
Also jetzt sozusagen dann die wertvollen äh Objekte, weil wir da viel mehr Wissenschaft machen kann. Genau zu wissen, wo ein Stern ist, ist eigentlich gar nicht so wichtig. Viel wichtiger ist, wie er sich bewegt und welche Entfernung er hat.
Zusammen mit Messgrößen wie äh für fast alle Sterne, die wir haben, haben wir auch die Helligkeitsmessung und die und die Messung wie helle im roten und im blauen Bereich ist.
Mhm. Das das ist diese diese Basismesse und die schon in diesem Early Data Release auch mit drin war, ne? Genau.
Haben wir für äh für eine eine kleinere Gruppe von Sternen haben wir jetzt äh auch die Spektren veröffentlicht und zwar gibt's da auch Qualitätskriterien und und Helligkeiten, da haben wir's also noch nicht für die ganz lichtschwachen Sterne
gemacht, weil wir bei denen noch nicht so sicher sind, dass man mit denen gut was anfangen kann, sondern wir wollen immer auch hochqualitative Daten erzeugen und nicht irgendwie
Dinge veröffentlichen
die wir vielleicht selber noch nicht bis zu dem Grund verstehen, das wird im Laufe der Zeit natürlich auch immer besser sein und äh mit den Astronomen auch wirklich was anfangen können.
Da gibt es also Helligkeitsgrenzen und deshalb sind das eben ähm ähm deutlich weniger als die eins Komma.
8 oder 1,5 Milliarden Sterne, für die man diese diese Daten hat und.
Äh ich muss mal den Mist müsst ihr jetzt mal ganz kurz einen Blick auf die Grafik äh wo mit den einzelnen Zahlen, dass sich das auch wirklich sehen kann.
Ah ja, ich glaube, ich weiß, welcher Sekunde ähm ja, äh war das nicht hier irgendwo.
Ja okay, das ist ähm das das ist aber der early Data Release, ne? Da da haben wir
Da kann man aber schon erkennen, also die 1,8 Milliarden Sterne haben die Sternposition und die untene Helligkeitsmessung im gesamten äh äh Spektralbereich äh dann im im
Blauen und einem roten haben wir ungefähr 1,5 Messen, sodass man da eine Farbe draus messen kann und für knapp 1,5 Milliarden haben wir äh Hellig Messung der Paralachse und der Entfernung und
genau jetzt nochmal zu dem drei.
Da findet man jetzt, dass die dass wir eben für 33 Milliarden Sternen die Radialgeschwindigkeit haben. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Das ist eine sehr kleine Nommzahl äh im Verhältnis zu den 1,5 Milliarden, aber da die Spektren natürlich ähm
Wellenlänge aufgespalten sind, haben wir natürlich weniger Licht, deshalb können wir nicht ganz so tief gehen
von der von der Lichtschwäche wie bei der bei den Messungen der der Astrometrie selber. Das werden aber am Ende wahrscheinlich äh im Bereich von 100 Millionen Sternen sein.
Dann haben wir diese niedrig aufgelösten Spektren für etwa 220 Millionen Sterne.
Und für diese Radialgeschwindigkeitsspektren, diese hoch aufgelösten Spektren die man auch dann zur Messung der Chemie äh des Sternes bestimmen kann, haben wir knapp eine Millionen
Spektren. Das werden deutlich mehr im Laufe der Zeit und.
Ja gucken sie ruhig auf die Seite wer sich wirklich genauer für alle Zahlen interessiert auf WWW Cosmo Punkt Cosmos Punkt ESA Punkt in. Es äh Slash äh
und da dann äh auf den Punkt äh DR drei gehen äh unter Data. Da können sie auf jeden Fall alle Daten finden äh mit den genauen Werten da. Es ist also jeder.
Von diesen Daten drin. Also die wertvollsten Daten sind natürlich die, für die wir.
Die Astrometrie haben, für die wir die äh Radialgeschwindigkeit haben, für die wir die äh niedrig äh und hochaufgelösten Spektren haben. Das sind von den Daten her die allerwichtigsten Sterne und äh.
Darauf warten natürlich die Astronomen, weil sie teilweise solche Spektren kann man teilweise vom Boden sogar mit höherer Qualität äh bekommen, aber niemals für eine so große Zahl von Sternen auf einmal.
Und wenn man jetzt findet in den Geierdaten
dass ein Stern besonders interessant ist von den Geierdaten selber, dann lohnt es sich manchmal auch mit einem anderen Instrument vielleicht mit James Web oder mit einem äh VLT äh Teleskop da nochmal hinzugucken, um irgendwelche
weiteren Messungen noch hinzuzufügen. Es ist nie so, dass die Geierdaten alleine.
Alle Lösungen der Rätsel, der Astronomie darstellen natürlich, sondern im Zusammenhang mit anderen Daten äh sind die Geier-Daten sehr wertvoll. Manchmal auch aus sich heraus schonen.
Ja, es ist so ein Starting Point, ne? Es ist halt äh äh etwas, da ist schon mal alles abgetastet äh worden und vor allem kann man ja dann auch
sagen, okay, was weiß ich, mich interessiert eine bestimmte Gattung von Sternen oder Sterne, die eine bestimmte.
Ja Geschwindigkeit haben, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, ne? Man forscht halt in alle möglichen Richtungen und dann kann man ja einfach direkt,
die Datenbank befragen, sagen okay, gib mal her und dann äh reduziert man das dann eben durch weitere Forschungen und dann sagt man, okay, das ist jetzt hier unser äh Bereich, da wo wir nochmal.
Aber ein ganz wichtiger Punkt für den ich mal kurz einschieben möchte, dadurch dass natürlich alle Daten irgendwo begrenzt sind, weil man von bestimmte wertvolle Daten nur für bestimmte Stellen haben, muss man sich auch immer klar machen, was sagt uns das jetzt über die Gruppe von allen Sternen aus
Warum warum bemessen wir, sagen wir mal, man macht bei jeder Art von Messung äh das ja immer eine Stichprobe über alle Sternen äh hinweg
äh genauso nehmen wir mal an, äh Meinungsumfrage. Da muss man ja auch kalibrieren, äh welches Alter haben die Leute, welche Bildungsabschluss haben die Leute, äh wohnen sie, welche Einkommen haben sie, wenn wenn man sie denn fragt, welche welche äh
Partei sie wählen oder welche welche äh was sie gerne kaufen oder was auch immer so in solchen Meinungsumfragen äh geschlossen wird
um dann daraus sozusagen zu sagen, was die Gesamtbevölkerung denkt, muss man eine Menge an an Kalibrationen auch da machen und genauso äh ist es auch für die Astronomie, dass man immer berücksichtigen muss
was man aus nicht sehen kann äh
zum Beispiel sehen wir ja sehr lichtschwache Sterne, die sehr, sehr geringe Leuchtkraft haben, nur in der unmittelbaren Umgebung unserer Sonne.
Dann die Sternen, diese lichtschwachen Sterne sehr schnell die 21ste Größenklasse wie ich die ich erwähnt habe als Grenzgröße erreicht haben und wir Sterne, die dann weiter weg sind gar nicht mehr sehen, müssen wir natürlich uns fragen, ja wie verteilen sie sich insgesamt.
Oder sehr helle Sterne, die sind sehr selten, sehr leuchtkräftige Sterne.
Ähm wie die kann man über ein viel größeres äh Volumen äh oder bis zu einer viel größeren Entfernung betrachten
und das muss man alles sozusagen dann auch modellieren um dann solche Beobachtungseffekte mit hineinzunehmen. Warum sehe ich äh in den Gajadaten nur die und die Daten. Das hat auch immer Gründe. Äh ähm die damit zusammenhängen.
Und äh nur dann kann man Wissenschaft und Statistik über Sterne machen am Ende, wenn man diese Dinge, solche Auswahleffekte, wie man sie nennt, dann auch richtig berücksichtigt.
Also diese Perspektiven finde ich jetzt auch nochmal interessant, würde ich auch gerne nochmal zwei, drei verschiedene Aspekte äh beleuchten. Also man muss ja immer klar machen,
Wir sind irgendwo so in unserer Milchstraße, um uns herum sind irgendwie sehr viele äh Sterne, ganz klar so da man hat diese super äh Dichte Mitte der Milchstraße, wo man fast schon nichts mehr so richtig aufgelöst bekommt und.
Jetzt haben wir 1,8 Milliarden Sterne äh quasi mal in den Fokus genommen und können für die zumindest mal sagen, okay, wir wissen äh wo die sind. Das ist natürlich im Verhältnis zu den 100 Millionen Plus, wieviel es auch immer genau.
Seinen äh hundert Milliarden natürlich äh Sternen so also man erfasst gerade mal so knapp zwei Prozent.
Davon ausgehen, von dem, was man derzeit so annimmt, wie viel es denn äh überhaupt ähm gibt. Das ist schon mal eine ganze Menge Holz.
So aber äh ist eben, sagen wir mal, auch nur so der der Anfang des des Blickes, aber daraus ergibt sich ja
ein Bild beziehungsweise wir haben ja letztes Mal auch schon ein bisschen drüber gesprochen, äh was für ein Bild sich denn daraus sozusagen ergibt, weil wir haben ja auch dieses.
Problem ist jetzt vielleicht nicht, aber.
Die Milchstraße nicht von außen fotografieren, weil sie wir sind ja drin. So und äh natürlich kann man jetzt über die beobachteten Sterne eine Annahme darüber machen, wie sieht's denn nun unsere Milchstraße,
aus, aber wir haben hier dieses klassische Spiralgalaxiebild, was ja eigentlich äh primär davon geprägt war, dass man irgendwann mal Andromeda.
Die nächste wirklich richtig große Galaxie gesehen hat, die so eine reine Spiralgalaxi ist und dann haben sich ja alle gedacht, so oh boah, die ist aber hübsch. Wir sind ja wahrscheinlich so ähnlich so, dann war das so wie das Bild und ähm
Hat sich das ein bisschen verändert durch die Beobachtung der letzten Jahrzehnte, dass man sagt, so ja, Spiralgalaxie schon, aber wahrscheinlich so eine Balkenspiralgalaxie.
Was sind denn jetzt für neue Erkenntnisse oder sind neue Erkenntnisse
kommen, wie denn die Mähstraße tatsächlich aussieht und inwiefern könnte man sie eben aus den Gajadaten heraus auch wirklich modellieren.
Also das sind auf jeden Fall wichtige neue Erkenntnisse, auf die ich auch gleich eingehen werde. Ähm ähm gekommen und zwar
ist es ja in der Tat so, dass dass man von anderen Galaxien ein einfaches Foto macht und dann sieht man, wie die Spiralarme aussehen, zumindest wenn man sie einigermaßen gut von oben sehen kann. Äh bei den
bei der Milchstraße haben wir zwar
Vorteil, dass wir die Sterne sehr nahe haben und deshalb auch alle Sterne sehr genau untersuchen können, aber den großräumigen Blick haben wir dadurch nicht so leicht und äh brauchen also die Entfernung der Sterne. Und dann muss man sich nochmal eine Sache klarmachen
Was sind denn eigentlich die Spiralarme in einer Galaxie? Sind das wirklich jetzt Gebiete, wo mehr Sterne sind.
Ja in begrenzten Weise ist das so, die da heißt die Sternendichte minimal höher als in den Bereichen zwischen den Spiralarmen. Äh aber warum sieht man die so deutlich? Das sieht die sieht man deshalb deutlich,
dort sehr helle, junge Sterne leuchten
Das heißt also, es sind Sterne, die grade geboren sind. Grade heißt natürlich nicht wie beim Menschen, sondern dass die vielleicht vor ein paar hundert äh
tausend oder paar Millionen Jahren geboren worden sind. Das sind sehr leuchtkräftige, meist auch sehr massereiche, junge Sterne. Das sind Sternentstehungsgebiete. Die wo die spiralarme sind und
leuchten die sehr hell und sie sorgen auch dafür, dass die Materie
äh äh zwischen den Sternen teilweise zum Leuchten angeregt werden durch den durch die der hellen, leuchtkräftigen jungen, auch sehr heißen Sterne.
Äh deshalb sieht man die Spiralarme so deutlich. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt mal überlegen wollen, wie sähe unsere Milchstraße
sozusagen von außen aus und wie wo sind die Spiralarme, dann sollten wir uns aus den Gajadaten die jungen Sterne, die hell leuchten heraussuchen.
Und äh das hat man natürlich gemacht.
Aber man muss natürlich da durchaus einige tausende von Lichtjahren überbrücken, also äh die die Entfernung in unserer Milchstraße sind ja doch riesig, also unsere Milchstraße hat so einen typischen Durchmesser von
00.000 Lichtjahren und um einen guten Überblick zu kriegen, muss man also tausende von Lichtjahren auch weit messen. Und selbst mit Gaja sind
einige tausend Lichtjahre weit weggehen, die hat man
paar Prozent Messfehler dann in der Entfernung. Das heißt äh aber das ist schon sehr sehr gut, was man da hat. Also man man kann also zumindest rund um die äh Milchstraße, nee um die Sonne
Positionen unserer Sonne, unseres Sonnensystems, wo Gaja misst, äh einige tausend
Lichtjahre heraus gut diese Sterne, ähm hellen Sterne finden mit Hilfe der Geierdaten, mit Hilfe der Farben, mithilfe der der ähm der Astrometrie mit Hilfe und deren Entfernungen sagen, wo die sind.
Wenn man sich das mal auf äh in einer Karte darstellt, dann zeigt sich.
Diese Spiralarme bei der Milchstraße wahrscheinlich nicht so stark ausgeprägt sind wie bei diesem berühmten Bild, was sie vielleicht, wenn sie auf Wikipedia gehen, sofort haben äh von dieser künstlerischen Darstellung der Milchstraße, die so.
So aussieht wie die M 51 Strudelgalaxide, wo man so typisches Beispiel einer es äh sogenannten SC-Spirale, wo man ganz deutliche Spiralarme hat. Wahrscheinlich ist es so, dass da.
Die ähm die Sterne und das sieht man an den Daten eben viel ähm auch stärker,
nicht so stark konzentrieren hin zu den Spiralarmen, aber die Spiralarme deutlich auch zu erkennen sind in dem
was wir von der Milchstraße haben. Das heißt also zumindest für einige tausend Lichtjahre rund um die Sonne können wir sagen wie die Spiralarme verlaufen.
Ein paar Messungen aus der Radioastronomie, wo man ein bisschen weiter messen kann, aber äh das sind sehr viel weniger Objekte. Das heißt, mit den Geierdaten hat man zum ersten Mal jetzt für eine große Zahl von.
Tausenden bis Millionen Objekten ein die Möglichkeit die Spiralarme sozusagen zu lokalisieren und.
Gibt es auch äh Karten, die die dichte Verteilung dieser jungen Sterne zeigt und die einem einen Eindruck geben, wie die Milchstraße dann aussieht,
Rest der Milchstraße, da muss man immer noch so ein bisschen ja künstlerische Darstellungen machen, die dann mit dem, was man in der Umgebung sieht, kompatibel sind.
Ganz sicher ist in der Mitte so eine Balkenspirale, das hat man auch schon vor Gaja gewusst und äh übrigens kann man diese Balkenspirale in der Orientierung auch mit den Geierdaten noch besser vermessen. Äh aber auf jeden Fall
haben wir eine gewisse Kartierung der Milchstraße, die aber bestimmt im Laufe der Mission auch noch weiter verbessert wird und da werden wir auch, wenn wir dann die Daten für,
die zehn Jahre oder zumindest für die fünf Jahre, das wird ja der nächste Sternkatalog sein
werden wir auch diese Position der Spiralarme nochmal genauer sehen können. Aber mit dem zwei und besonders jetzt auch mit dem Release drei haben wir schon eine sehr sehr gute
der dichte Verteilung der der jungen Sterne und können sagen, wie die Spiralarme um die Sonne herum aussehen.
Ist daraus jetzt sozusagen auch schon eine neue Erkenntnis äh gewonnen worden, was man meint, wie die Milchstraße nun aussehen würde, würde man sie jetzt von Andromeda aus fotografieren? Also.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist dann eine eine ähm ja etwas wie man sagen wir mal sie die die wirklichen Messungen der Geierdaten dann in ein
künstlerisches Bild immer noch sozusagen
Darstellung, welches kompatibel ist, denn wir müssen ja ausgehen, dass die das Verhalten in unserer Sonnenumgebung ein typisches Verhalten ist. Das heißt also, dass es nicht auf der anderen Seite jetzt ganz plötzlich ganz scharfe Spiralarme sind, auf der anderen Seite total unscharfe. Das,
das machen Galaxien nicht. Äh das wissen wir von anderen Galaxien, das heißt also wir
damit schon ein Bild machen, aber dieses Bild wird nicht in allen Bereichen natürlich äh ähm ganz genau sein und das wird man auch mit äh in absehbarer Zeit nicht schaffen. Äh.
Ja gut, vielleicht ist es nicht genau, aber ich meine es gibt ja einen Trainer. Also ich meine, ich hab's nicht so verfolgt, aber was ich so bisschen mitbekommen äh habe, also erstmal war ja sozusagen
das war so erstmal äh so der der erste Zwischenstand, so okay. Wahrscheinlich sind wir nicht genauso wie Androme da, sondern äh eben so mit so einem Balken. Dann ähm
hieß es die das äh die Milchstraße hat eine sehr viel höhere vertikale Ausdehnung, also jetzt im Verhältnis zu der eigentlichen.
Plane, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man's nennen soll.
Ebene, genau. Äh ja, dass dass es höher sei, als man angenommen hat. Das äh habe ich noch so ein bisschen mitgenommen. Ähm.
Andere Parameter, die sich so in den letzten Jahren und vielleicht auch durch Gaja jetzt äh ändern.
Also also man versteht inzwischen auch diese diese Dicke der Scheibe zum Beispiel besser, weil man weiß, dass die Milchstraße, das gilt übrigens natürlich auch für andere Galaxien im Laufe der Zeit.
Ja nicht alleine war, sondern immer mehr auch mit kleineren Galaxien, Zwerggalaxien, aber auch größeren Zwerggalaxinen äh Wechsel gewirkt hat, die dann im Laufe der Zeit auch mit der Milchstraße teilweise verschmolzen sind
und man geht davon aus, dass bei einer Verschmelzung
einer Galaxie, die man heute aus den in Kellerus nennt, das ist eine Galaxidi Wohl für etwa zehn Milliarden Jahren äh mit unserer Milchstraße verschmolzen ist, dass die dazu geführt hat.
Die ähm die Scheibe der Milchstraße dicker geworden ist, weil einfach durch die Gravitationswirkung dieser Galaxie und ähm
diese Sterne, die mal aus dieser
Gaja im Kellerdos Galaxie gekommen sind, die bewegen sich heute immer noch anders als viele andere Sterne in der Galaxie. Und jetzt und da die Geier-Daten ja so hervorragend.
Bewegung der Sterne messen kann, kann man diese Sterne
anhand ihrer Bewegungen alleine schon sehr gut identifizieren, wenn man dann noch hinzunimmt die chemische Zusammensetzung und bestimmte Spektraleigenschaften, dann kann man wirklich.
Sagen, dass ein Großteil oder ein Filet der Sterne, die sie sozusagen die Milchstraße insgesamt umgeben, das was man in den Halo einer Galaxie nennt.
Ausfüllen und äh dass dort äh man die Sterne, diese Geier in Kellerdossterne noch identifizieren kann und die hat haben äh.
Eben wahrscheinlich eben auch dazu der zu der Verformung der Galaxie auch der Verdickung der Galaxie äh in dem Fall geführt und.
Kann man tatsächlich aus den Gaja-Daten schließen. Das hat man in äh schon ein aus dem Gaja-DR zwei, über den wir das letzte Mal geredet haben, beschlossen, aber man hat das natürlich jetzt auch mit den neuen Gajadaten untersucht und äh
bestätigt und jetzt auch für mehr Objekte noch äh gemessen, denn dazu braucht man möglichst die IG-Sterne, die
die wir alle Raumkomponenten haben, also diese 3unddreißig Millionen Sterne untersucht und da findet man denn welche Sterne gehören zu diesem Ereignis, was vor zehn Milliarden Jahren einmal stattfand
Und dieses Ereignis war es durchaus signifikant. Die Milchstraße war nämlich noch nicht so groß, wie sie heute ist. Sie ist noch gewachsen, nämlich hat nämlich im Laufe der Zeit andere ähm.
Kleinere Objekte dann äh integriert. Wahrscheinlich war diese äh Gaja in Kellerdos Galaxie
hatte wahrscheinlich ein Viertel der Masse unserer Milchstraße, also waren schon nicht mehr das, was man so ein typisches Zwergalaxie nennt, sondern schon ein größeres Objekt. Das war wahrscheinlich das einflussreichste Ereignis in der Geschichte der Milchstraße
Und solche hat man mehr gefunden, also man man kennt sozusagen Ströme von Sternen, die äh aus solchen ähm
galaktischen Ereignissen kommen und man kann also aus den Gajadaten viele solche Ereignisse identifizieren, viele solche Sternströme auf
Begegnung mitverfolgen sodass wir auch ein Bild haben, wie unsere Milchstraße im Laufe der Zeit ähm ja sich entwickelt hat, auch in der Begegnung mit kleineren Galaxien.
Die ähm also diese ganzen geschluckten Galaxien, die sind sozusagen so eine eigene.
Struktur in der Struktur oder man kann sie zumindest zurückrechnen, ne. Also man kann dann quasi, könnte man ja, gibt's ja wahrscheinlich auch schon so Animationen, wie dann die dann wohl vermutlich mal auf die Milchstraße aufgeschlagen ist, als es dann eben soweit war.
Über die Zeit äh verortet hat, das heißt das ist ja auch so ein Metadatum, dass man im Prinzip jedem Stern
Nicht im Geierkatalog, aber so generell äh so als Attribut auch sagen kann, okay du bist wahrscheinlich aus,
Dieser Verschmelzung hervorgegangen. Ähm.
Um mal eine Ebene kleiner äh zu gehen. Da hatten wir letztes Mal auch schon drüber gesprochen, aber es stand auch noch so ein bisschen im Raum, ob da jetzt neue Erkenntnisse sind. Äh.
Die Sonne und ihre Nachbar.
Also so wie's ja in der gesamten Galaxie Zusammengehörigkeiten gibt, wie zum Beispiel aus welcher Galerie bin ich denn geschickt worden? Ähm,
Dann auch diese Sternhaufen, den
teilweise eben einfach aus derselben Geburtsphase her resultieren oder eben aus anderen Gründen wissen wir denn jetzt
wer so unsere Schwestersonnen sind oder Bruder sollen meistens die Sonne ja immer männlich in den meisten Sprachen ist ja nur bei uns anders. Also ähm.
Gibt's noch so einen lokalen Bereich,
jetzt ausmachen kann, wo man sagen kann so, ah okay, das ist hier so unsere Hood, das ist so irgendwie das, was sich bei uns so mitgebildet hat, dazugehört, die gleiche Richtung fliegt, so äh hat das einen Namen.
Das ist sehr, sehr schwierig, weil ähm da gibt's mehrere Dinge zu zu sagen. Also so ein Sternhaufen, der ist ja tatsächlich eine ein Gebiet, wo
viele Sterne gleichzeitig aus einer großen Molekülwolke entstanden sind, die dann durch die Gravitation unter bestimmten Bedingungen und äh der Temperatur und der Druckverhältnisse.
Zur Sternbildung geführt haben und ähm ähm ob unsere Sonne mal in einem solchen Sternhaufen geboren ist, ist übrigens nicht klar. Es gibt
die in Sternhofen geboren sind. Das sind sehr viele wohl äh aber wie viele äh relativ zu den Einzelstellen, das ist äh nicht mal unbedingt sehr klar. Aber was wir wissen ist,
die Sterne, die zum Beispiel jetzt gerade unsere Sohn Nähe sind, keinesfalls immer äh in der Sonnennähe waren, denn
Wenn man äh es gibt so eine schöne Simulation, die wir auch gemacht haben oder die der Stefan gemacht hat, die man sich auf YouTube auch angucken kann, die zeigt, dass die äh.
Sterne, die wir jetzt in der Sonnenumgebung haben. Da die sind also in dem Fall geht es um Sterne, die jetzt nur hundert Paar Sekt, das sind 326 Lichtjahre von uns entfernt sind. Das ist so eine Kugel im Moment sozusagen alle Sterne, die da drin sind.
Über die nächsten Millionen Jahre weiterverfolgt.
Äh und äh unsere Sonne ja um die Milchstraße wandert, aber jeder Stern, der wandert nicht zusammen mit unserer Sonne, ganz genau, sondern die haben ganz
Bahnen teilweise. Wenn wir das jetzt mal weiter simuliert, dann verstreut sich das enorm, selbst nach einem Umlauf
sind die Sterne schon lange nicht mehr auch nur in der Nähe von unserer.
Sonne. Das heißt und manchmal kommen die dann auch ein bisschen wieder zusammen. Das ist ganz witzig, dass da auch auch auch Periodis, äh Bahnen drin sind, wo man also sich hin und wieder mal wiederfindet,
aber über den Zeitraum von viereinhalb Milliarden Jahren. Unsere Sonne ist ja vor viereinhalb, 4,6 Milliarden Jahren entstanden über diesen Zeitraum
sind die so verstreut, dass man soweit niemals zurückrechnen kann, also dass man zumindest für den Einzelstellen und sagen, dieser Stern, der war mal in der Nähe der Sonne, also das das ist wirklich unmöglich.
Das gilt für für keinen ein.
Das gilt im Prinzip für keinen einzelnen Stern über solchen Zeitraum.
Also es wird doch alleine.
Ja ja
aber es kann durchaus sein, dass unsere Sonne natürlich so geboren ist und es gibt eine kleine Spekulation, dass äh so ein kosmisches Ereignis, wie ich das beschrieben habe mit dem Verschmelzen der Milchstraße.
Durchaus mit der Entstehungsgeschichte unserer Sonne ein bisschen zu tun hat, nämlich äh die sogenannte Sakretarius Zwerggalaxi. Das ist eine, die auf der anderen Seite im Moment
Milchstraße steht, von der Sonne aus gesehen haben wir das galaktische Zentrum und dahinter befindet sich jetzt gerade diese und die läuft ein paar Mal
um die Milchstraße herum und verschmilzt auch äh irgendwann mal mit unserer Milchstraße stärker. Aber sie war einmal vor
Es gab mal eine nahe Begegnung vor etwa 6 Milliarden Jahren. Das kann man übrigens ganz gut zurückrechnen, dass es solch eine Begegnung gab. Und jetzt ist so Idee, dass wenn sie so eine.
Zwerggalaxie nahe der galaktischen Scheibe ist, dass dort Druckwellen entstehen, die dazu führen
dort so Verdichtungen in der sich bilden und dann eine höhere Sternanstehungsrate damit verbunden ist. Und ähm die kann also durchaus zu einem Sternenentstehung geführt haben, die dann über
ein, 2 Milliarden Jahre noch andauerte, sodass die äh Entstehung unserer Sonne vielleicht mit diesem Ereignis sogar zusammengehängt haben könnte,
dort eine höhere Entsternestehung war. Aber es ist noch mehr ein bisschen spekulativ. Man äh es gibt andere Analysen, wo es um die Sternentstehungsraten gehen, wo auch andere Ergebnisse hervorkommen, aber das ist zumindest eine gute Möglichkeit, dass so eine
zum Beispiel mit,
Galaxie dazu geführt hat. Übrigens diese Sagettariusgalaxie hat wahrscheinlich auch dazu geführt, dass unsere Milchstraßenebene eben gar keine richtige Ebene ist, sondern auch verbogen ist,
auch das da gibt es schöne Animationen die das zeigen die die wie verbogen die Milchstraße ist und diese Verbiegung ist eben auch durch.
Wechselwirkung. Also unsere.
Ripple, so einen Ripple-Effekt, als wenn man was ins Wasser schmeißt.
Ganz genau. Aber wie gesagt äh wir können ein bisschen was darüber sagen und es ist auch durchaus möglich, dass unsere Sonne nicht in der Entfernung
entstanden ist, die vom galaktischen Zentrum, wo sie heute steht. Es ist zum Beispiel ganz interessant, dass unsere Sonne
eine relativ hohe Menge von schweren Elementen in ihrer Sternatmosphäre enthält.
Und äh wenn man das jetzt mal vergleicht mit den jungen Sternen in der Sonnenumgebung, die ja eigentlich sozusagen später entstanden sind, wo eigentlich sogar mehr im Laufe der Zeit werden ja
wird ja das galaktische Material angereichert mit schweren Elementen, die ja in Sternen erbrütet wurden. Im Urknall sind ja nur Wasserstoff Helium, ein ganz klein bisschen Lithium entstanden. Alles andere ist ja mal ein Stern entstanden und kann nur durch Supernova-Explosion oder durch Sternenwinde wieder ans Unterstelle, medium gegeben werden. Also
Erde besteht ja aus schweren Elementen. Unser Körper besteht zu einem erheblichen Teil aus schweren Elementen. Äh das ist alles später entstanden und
Sonne muss also auch ein Stern sein, der sich schon angereichert hat damit. Und aber
Rund um die Sonne gibt es viele Sternen, die eine geringere Metallizität wie die Astronomen das nennen, zum Unglauben der Chemiker, die die natürlich eine ganz andere Definition von Metallen haben. Äh.
Und das kann also sein, dass unsere Sonne vielleicht aus einem Gebiet gestammt ist, was näher am galaktischen Zentrum gewesen ist. Es gibt also paar Anzeichen, aber das können wir nicht wirklich hundertprozentig.
Aber wir sind definitiv auch in der Milchstraße entstanden, das weiß man. Wir sind jetzt nicht so von außen eingetragen oder so.
Davon davon muss man ausgehen.
Okay, also.
Aber wie gesagt, das äh.
Kann also sein, dass da also durchaus eine Menge steht. So weit kann man für diesen Einzelstern das sehr, sehr schwer zurückrechnen, aber man kann natürlich Modellierungen machen, die einem sagen kann, das alles kann mit der Milchstraße oder mit den nicht mit der Milchstraße, aber
und mit unserer Sonne geschehen sein. Da gibt es also verschiedene Modelle, aber die sind noch nicht zu einem ja, endgültigen Ergebnis gekommen.
Okay, also ich nehme daraus jetzt mal mit äh nach aktuellem Erkenntnisstand gibt es jetzt keine unmittelbare äh lokale Struktur äh zu der die Sonne so gehört, die sich derzeit so erkennen lässt.
Ja? Okay, weil ich meine, wenn man ins Große schaut und es würde ja ein bisschen nahe liegen.
Man kennt so die ganzen Supercluster und Filamente und so weiter, also umso weiter man ins Universum reinschaut, bilden sich da ja so Strukturen und Gruppen ab und es gibt Lehrräume und es
Füllräume und irgendwie würde man auch habe ich zumindest bisher äh erwartet, dass man ähnliche Strukturen
auch so in der Galaxis selber, okay, war eine Spirale haben wir und so weiter, aber äh dass es sich vielleicht lokal noch ähm mehr Strukturen nachweisen lässt, aber es ist dann wohl.
Na ja, also man man man sieht sehr viele Strukturen, zum Beispiel eben von diesen aufgelösten Begegnungen von Galaxien, die dann
durch die Gezeitenkräfte, durch die Gravitation zerrissen wurden und die dann dazu führen, dass wir solche Sternströme haben in unserer Galaxie, die wir ja
Gaja jetzt hoch genau vermessen können. Äh das kann man alles sehen und und man sieht viele Strukturen, aber man kann jetzt nicht sagen genau aus welcher Struktur unsere Sonne kommt.
Ja, okay
Ja diese Sternströme, das hatten wir ja letztes Mal ja auch schon angesprochen, ich finde äh also ich finde ja allein schon das Wort für dich ja irgendwie irre, also so diese Vorstellung, dass also wirklich äh so ein Fluss.
Von Sternen irgendwo äh durch
zieht, aber dem ist ja so. In dem Moment, wo man das visualisiert und äh sagt, okay, jetzt gehen wir aber hier mal so richtig auf Speed und jeder Frame äh überspringt hunderttausende von Jahren, dann merkt man, dass da so äh richtig Leben in der Bude ist.
Genau.
Das ist das kann man eben wie gesagt äh sagen und dafür ist natürlich der Geierdatensatz der Datensatz, der einem da mehr liefert. Vorher hat man sehr, sehr viele äh Dinge schon entdeckt, äh dadurch, dass man zum Beispiel
da die Entfernung nicht so genau gemessen hat wie mit Gaja, sondern deren, deren äh ja den modelliert hat und sozusagen indirekt geschlossen haben, welche Entfernungen die haben müssen und äh und und natürlich hat man die
die Geschwindigkeitsmessung nicht so genau gehabt, aber mit kann man das jetzt mehr entdecken, weitere Ströme entdecken und man kann die, die man
gekannt hat äh natürlich viel genauer vermessen und das ist dann natürlich eine Sache von den Leuten, die äh Simulation machen, wie.
Galaktische Potential aller Objekte in unserer Milchstraße, denn auf so einen Sternstrom wirkt und die Bewegung von jedem einzelnen Stern ist ja beeinflusst durch die Masse und alle anderen Objekte in der Milchstraße.
Blicken wir mal kurz außerhalb der Milchstraße, die ja natürlich Fokus eigentlich von Geier ist, aber da ist ja in anderen Galaxien eben auch.
Manche helle Sterne gibt, fallen die ja dann sozusagen auch noch in die äh über diesen Freshold, äh den Gaja registriert mit rein beziehungsweise man sieht auf jeden Fall von sehr vielen Galaxien, die schon erwähnten Quasare, also diese leuchtenden Zentren der äh Galaxien
Gab's da jetzt sozusagen auch neue äh Erkenntnisse? Also wir hatten ja schon.
Auch wiederum ganz gute Startkerzen beziehungsweise Posten Posten, Leuchttürme quasi.
Wir haben jetzt ähm äh es gab jetzt auch einen extra Katalog innerhalb von drei, der äh und äh Galaxien.
Umfasste. Und zwar ist es so, dass wir ja für viele dieser Objekte, auch diese zumindest niedrig aufgelösten Sternspektren auch haben.
Und das heißt, wir können ähm zum Beispiel bei Quarsaren, die haben ganz starke.
Emissionslinien in dem Fall ähm in der Wellenlänge vermessen
Darauf können wir sogar aus den Geierdaten selber schon deren Rotverschiebung äh messen.
Also deren Bewegung im All.
Die Bewegung im All und zwar die mit der kosmischen Umgebung, mit dem mit dem Urknall sozusagen, mit dem, was nach dem Urknall geschehen ist, dass die Galaxien auseinander streben und eben auch die Quasare.
Dass sie äh umso schneller von uns sich entfernen, je weiter sie entfernt sind durch diese kosmologische Bewegung der ähm.
Dunkle Energie kommt jetzt immer mehr dazu im Laufe der Entwicklung des Universums äh ähm spielt das
immer mehr eine Rolle. Es dehnt sich also, wie wir wissen, äh beschleunigt aus, aber wir haben, wie gesagt, für für viele neue äh Galaxien äh und
äh deren Rotverschiebung zum Beispiel auch messen können, ne? Ohne dass man jetzt auch vom Erdboden kann man das auch sehr schön machen, aber äh es ist sozusagen ein großer Datensatz
womit man jetzt das äh machen konnte. Und natürlich ist das Untersampel der Kawasare wichtig wie ich vorhin erwähnte eben auch für die Kalibration von Gaja selber. Das ist eine Sache
Und wenn wir jetzt mal ein bisschen zu den näheren Galaxien kommen. Also es ist ja so, dass unsere Milchstraße hat ja Nachbarn, du hast den Andromedanebel erwähnt und
Es gibt ein paar andere Galaxien und ein paar viele kleine Zwerggalaxien, die sich äh auch in zur sogenannten lokalen Gruppe gehören. Und da sieht man in der Tat auch einzelne Sterne drin, äh deren Bewegungen man messen kann und
Zwar ist es so, dass man jetzt mit Hilfe der Geierdaten sogar sehen kann, die wie die Rotation im Andromedanebel zum Beispiel ist, wie die Sterne sich
um den Atommedanebel herumbewegen, also so genau kann Gaja jetzt schon mit den
jetzt nur auf 34 Monat beruhenden Datenkatalog äh eine Aussage treffen und das ist natürlich nach zehn Jahren wir wissen wir sind noch viel viel detaillierter.
Und wir können vor allen Dingen ganz wichtig messen, wie sich
Galaxien selber bewegen, denn die Sterne da drin bewegen sich zwar um den und haben eine Rotation um dieses Zentrum, aber das ist wesentlich langsamer als sich die Galaxie selber bewegt
wir können also gucken mit welcher Geschwindigkeit sich zum Beispiel der Andromedanebel durchs All bewegt. Wie schnell er auf uns zukommt
von uns weg. Das kann man von der Erde supergenau messen mit Hilfe des Doppler-Effektes, aber wie sozusagen die seine Querbewegung ist, das wissen wir noch nicht genau.
Weiß ja schon lange, dass der Andromedanebel mal äh mit der Milchstraße verschmelzen wird.
Was jetzt dann genau geschieht, das hängt sehr stark von dieser Querbewegung an. Wie nah kommt denn
der Andromedanee will jetzt unserem galaktischen Zentrum sozusagen. Davon hängt ab, was man mit der Milchstraße oder dem Gemeinsamen dann verschmolzenen Produkt aus der Milchstraße und dem Andromi daneben mal geschieht. Das heißt, wenn wir die äh wenn wir die Geierdaten noch weiter verfolgen, dann kann man äh
eine sehr gute Simulation machen, was mal mit diesem Objekt geschehen kann. Besser als man das bisher konnte
Und man kann für viele Zwerggalaxien, die sich um die Milchstraße bewegen, äh sagen, wie sie sich tatsächlich welche Eigenbewegungen sie haben
jetzt mit den Geierdaten schon möglich und wird in
großen endgültigen Datensatz äh mit einer extrem hohen Genauigkeit messen kann. Also wir können also nicht nur die Bewegung der Sterne in unserer Milchstraße messen, sondern auch die das Verhalten der Galaxien in unserer lokalen Gruppe sehr genau äh.
Darstellen.
Dreiunddreißig war ja auch noch so eine gehört auch noch zu lokalen Gruppen.
Die drei, die drei großen Galaxien sind die äh Milchstraße, der die Andromeda Galaxien und dann äh mit einem deutlichen Abstand die der DM 33 und dann gibt es viele äh Galaxien, die man Zwerggalaxin nennen würde.
Ja, M dreiunddreißig ist ja äh bekannt geworden, weil dort das Schwarze Loch sozusagen visualisiert wurde.
Nein, nein, das war M siebenundachtzig.
M siebenundachtzig. Ah, habe ich verwechsel.
Ja ja, das ist ein das ist ein das ist ein sehr viel weiter entferntes Objekt als die als M dreiunddreißig.
Man kommt durcheinander bei den Zahlen.
Schwarze Löcher gibt's in praktisch allen Zentren von Galaxien, aber aber äh um sie aufzunehmen müssen sie sehr, sehr groß sein und bei M 78 ist es so, dass das einen so
großes, schwarzes Loch ist, dass man das selbst von der Erde aus mit den speziellen Radio astronomischen Techniken, Interphherometrischen tatsächlich vermessen konnte. So wie man dann auch später das äh.
Milchstraßen schwarze Loch messen konnte.
Genau.
Dann blicken wir doch noch mal auf das Sonnensystem, weil Gaja natürlich zwangsläufig auch alles irgendwie äh vor die Linse bekommt, was in unserem Sonnensystem her so herumfliegt. Das bedeutet, man sieht natürlich die Planeten. Ich weiß nicht, darüber wird wahrscheinlich.
Wird wahrscheinlich nicht groß neue Erkenntnisse gebracht haben vermute ich mal. Ähm so wie äh Gaja auf die Umgebung blickt, aber eben auf diese lichtschwachen Objekte, die Asteroiden. Äh derer es ja eine Menge gibt
So ähm die fallen dann schon.
Erwähnt es auch Spektrennen dann natürlich auch äh gebildet werden können, was uns dann auch über die Zusammensetzung der Asteriden nochmal was Neues äh sagt. Das fand also statt.
Ja, also Asteroiden äh waren immer geplant, dass sie von Gaja natürlich vermessen werden und ähm die das sind äh sind äh ja Objekte, die natürlich durch die Fokalebene von Gaja laufen und deshalb natürlich mit gemessen werden
und wir haben für mit dem drei jetzt ein Katalog von hundertfünfzigtausend
Asteroiden, die im Gaja DR3-Katalog drin sind und für die für die Bahnbestimmung, die Geierdaten selber benutzt worden sind
und viele von den Daten sind äh schon mit den 34 Monaten, auf denen das beruht jetzt besser als das, was man mit
hunderten von Jahren teilweise na ja oder vielen Jahrzehnten zumindest für die meisten,
Beobachtung gewonnen hat und im Laufe der Zeit wird das natürlich noch viel, viel genauer. Das heißt, die Bewegung der Asteroiden äh kann man äh deutlich genauer irgendwann erfassen und teilweise jetzt schon erfassen, als man's bisher kannte.
Aber was ganz wichtig ist, ist, dass man für diese Asteroiden auch diese niedrig aufgelösten Sternspektren hat.
Und äh es ist ja so, was sieht man von einem Asteroiden im Spektrum? Da sieht man eigentlich, dass reflektierte Sonnenlicht.
Das ist die leuchten ja nicht selber wie Sterne, sondern die reflektieren das und wie viel sie von der abhängig von der äh Wellenlänge reflektieren, hängt natürlich von der von der Chemie
welche Steine, welches Gestein an der Oberfläche ist, ob das irgendwelche Silikate oder äh äh irgendwelche kohlstoffreichen äh Verbindungen sind. Ich bin da jetzt kein Mineraloge und kenne mich da auch sehr sehr
aus, aber es ist so, dass man für ähm ungefähr ähm achttausend.
Der Asteroiden bisher von der Erde aus äh solche Spektren gemessen hat. Und mit denen könnte man klassifizieren, welche
welche chemische Zusammensetzung die einzelnen Asteroiden haben. Jetzt mit Gaja haben wir jetzt fünfundfünfzigtausend.
Solcher Spektren. Das heißt, wir haben eine erhebliche Vergrößerung des Samples, für die wir jetzt etwas wissen über die chemische Zusammensetzung.
Ein ganz interessanter äh Punkt, den man auch schon vorher äh ohne die Geier-Daten identifiziert hat, aber was man jetzt noch wieder genauer sehen kann, ist, dass äh viele der Asteroiden mal.
Aus der Kollision von größeren Asteroiden entstanden sind oder dadurch, dass ein.
Ein größerer Brocken mal auf einen größeren Asteroiden gefallen sind und das Material dann herausgeschleudert ist, denn das hat teilweise die gleiche chemische Zusammensetzung wie der dieses Mutterobjekt und äh
Bahnen sind immer noch äh identifizierbar, dass sie dazu gehören. Also wenn man es gibt so einen schönen schöne Grafik, wo man.
Bahndaten sozusagen aufträgt, zum Beispiel die der Abstand von der Sonne und die Exzentrizität, also wie elektrisch die Bahn ist und dann einfärbt äh
chemische Zusammensetzung die haben, dann gibt es so Gruppen, das sind man kann also etwa hundert so Asteroiden Familien, so nennt man die, identifizieren
und und dieser Plot ist jetzt deutlich besser geworden, wenn man das vergleicht mit dem, was man äh vorher, vor Gaja hatte, kann man das jetzt viel genauer sehen. Das heißt also, auch über die Entwicklung des Asteroidengürtels kann man natürlich viel bessere Modelle jetzt machen.
Wildschweinfamilien, die so um den Wald herumziehen, ja und dann nehme ich auch an, sind auch neue Astroidenten gefunden worden oder kannte man das.
Paar, ein Paar, es ist so, dass die das Gaja in den Daten versteckt äh garantiert ganz viele Objekte hat, die vielleicht noch nicht
da gewesen sind, aber muss sie auch zusammenführen. Man muss äh macht ja sozusagen Aufnahmen von den Objekten, die jetzt gerade durch das Fokalebene tun, kommen und bei Sternen, da weiß man, dass die sich relativ langsam bewegen und sie ja nicht jetzt äh
gewaltig woanders sind, während ein Asteroid, der hat bei unserer nächsten Beobachtung.
Völlig andere Position am Himmel, weil die ja typischerweise eine Bewegung habe, die nur wenige Jahre laufen, die einmal um die Sonne herum, das heißt, die sind ganz woanders,
und die dann zusammenzubringen, dieses was man Cross-Matching nennt, der Daten, die dass sie zu einem Objekt gehören. Das ist bei Asteroiden unglaublich schwierig.
Ähm man kann, wenn man.
Aber das Spektrum dann wieder genauer.
Ja, das kann sein, aber das das wird noch nicht wirklich benutzt dafür bisher. Es ist so, dass manchmal Gaja ja,
ein Asteroiden vielleicht ein paar Mal gemessen hat und dann wieder Monate nicht misst.
Und es gibt so ein paar Projekte, wo sich übrigens auch Amateurastronomen dran beteiligen können, äh solche Messungen dann ein paar Tage später nochmal vom
Boden aus, sich anzugucken, dann kann man nicht gucken, äh wo steht der ein paar Tage nach der Gaja-Messung und dann kann man besser vorhersagen, äh wo er wo er dann vielleicht in ein paar Monaten stehen wird und dann kann man nachgucken wiederum was dazugehört. Das das das kann helfen, die Sachen zusammenzuführen. Aber in der Tat ist das noch nicht so richtig für die große Gruppe
von Asteroiden gelungen, aber auch das ist eine Sache,
natürlich in Zukunft äh sich verbessern wird. Da wird man also auch viele weitere Objekte in den Daten finden. Aber muss nicht immer klar machen, die die Manpower äh äh die man im Moment da reingesteckt hat, die hat eben
war im Moment genutzt worden, die bekannten Objekte in Gaja zu identifizieren, genauere Bahnmessungen zu machen und diese Spektren zu messen.
Und äh alles andere äh entwickelt sich auch weiter und neue
Objekte werden sicherlich gefunden. Aber nicht in einer riesigen Zahl jetzt, äh die das als ähm sagen wir, Entdeckungsmaschine für für Asteroiden,
begreifen würde,
interessanter Aspekt ist, dass wenn wir jetzt die mit Gaja, die Asteroiden genau vermessen können und die Sterne, dann passiert es ja hin und wieder mal.
Ein Asteroid von einem äh einen Stern bedeckt vor der Erde ausgesehen.
Äh dass wenn die nur ein paar Kilometer groß sind, dann werfen sie sozusagen von dem Stern auch nur einen kleinen Schatten auf der Erde.
Es gibt Amateurastronomen, die ihre Teleskope dort aufstellen, wo vorhergesagt wurde, wo so eine Bedeckung stattfindet und dann kann man aus der Zeit, die
zwischen dem Verschwinden und wieder auftauchen des Asteroiden zum Beispiel deren Durchmesser messen und sogar deren Form messen, wenn man ganz viele Beobachter hat.
Und bisher war es so,
oft Diebst, weder die Sternposition noch die Position des Asteroiden so gut bekannt war, dass man den sehr genau sagen konnte, wo die Beobachtung stattfand, da waren also war's oft so, dass es dann auch so war, dass man vorher gesagt hat, da stattfindet was statt und dann fand gar nichts statt.
Oder umgekehrt stand dann statt, aber da war kein Beobachter
kann man jetzt heute viel genauer sagen können, das heißt die die Anzahl der Fehlbeobachtungen ist wesentlich kleiner geworden und das sind sehr wertvolle Ergebnisse, weil man durch solche Bedeckungen
sehen kann, dass da vielleicht noch ein zweiter Asteroid ist in der Nähe. Das gibt nämlich inzwischen viele Doppelasteroiden und es gibt manchmal sogar Ringe um einen Asteroiden, dass da vor dieser Bedeckung
kurzzeitig schon mal das Licht ein bisschen verschwunden ist, dann wieder aufgetaucht ist, dann hat der Asteroid die Bedeckung gemacht und dann ist das auf der anderen Seite nochmal passiert. Äh solche Beobachtungen sind unglaublich wertvoll und
da gibt es also eine richtig große Gruppe von Amateuren, die jetzt froh sind, dass die Geierdaten so gut sind, dass man solche Messungen äh deutlich verbessern kann. Also,
Gibt es also viele interessante und sehr aktive Leute, die gar nicht ähm ja Berufsastronomen sind, aber viel Spaß äh die Wissenschaft hier zu unterstützen.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, die meisten dieser Astrid sind befinden sich im Astridengürtel, die jetzt hier gefunden wurde, aber es gibt ja noch einen Körpergürtel sozusagen, wo dann halt auch so die
tunischen äh Objekte rumlungern und die sind ja in den letzten Jahren zu ähm,
besonderer Berühmtheit gekommen, weil man erstmal eine ganze Menge neue also größere Strukturen entdeckt hat
Ja, was ja letzten Endes auch Pluto so ein bisschen seinen Planetenstatus gekostet hat, weil man festgestellt hat, dass er so besonders dann auch nicht äh ist schon immer ein bisschen weird war
super hübsch aussieht. Muss man auch mal dazu sagen. Also äh nichts gegen Pluto, aber das Ganze ist ja dann auch äh nochmal so.
Heftiger in die Diskussion gekommen wegen der Diskussion um nein, also der mögliche 9te Planet, den's vielleicht gibt oder nicht so und ob's den gibt oder nicht, ob die Daten, die man bisher darauf hinweisen oder nicht. Darüber ist glaube ich die ganze äh.
Ganze Astrogemeinde fünfzig, 50 gespalten, habe ich so den Eindruck. Ähm jetzt könnte's ja sein, dass Gaja auch irgendwas äh gesehen hat.
Äh hat man nicht, also man von den transnekturischen Objekten hat Gaja so ungefähr ein Dutzend sehr gut vermessen bisher. Also.
Ähm aber äh man hat keine weiteren gefunden und die Objekte werden wahrscheinlich auch sehr stark im Infraroten sein. Wenn's diesen Planeten neun gibt, dann
er mit Gaja sehr, sehr schwer überhaupt zu sehen sein und dann auch noch äh die Daten richtig zusammenzubringen, also sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich. Es ist auch
sehr umstritten, ob diese Idee von den Planeten neun natürlich richtig ist. Da gibt's ja äh ein paar Hinweise aus den Bahnen der bekannten transnatürlichen Objekte, diese sehr großen Objekte, die durchaus teilweise ähm Durchmesser haben, die vergleichbar sind mit dem, was Pluto sind
kleiner, aber jetzt nicht irgendwie
Hundertstel oder Zehntel, sondern auch durchaus also äh größere Durchmesser haben so äh und Macke Marke und wie sie alle heißen da draußen
und äh die Bahn haben da sind ein bisschen asymmetrisch, sind nicht gleich verteilt, deshalb hat man diesen Schluss gemacht, also äh es ist aber sehr umstritten, ob das eine Rolle.
Denn die Bahnen dieser Objekte genauer bestimmt werden erstmal.
Nein, bisher ähm gibt es keine Daten. Also ich ich weiß nicht, ich bin jetzt auch nicht der der Superspezialist für in der Gruppe. Ich bin nicht in der Gruppe, die diese äh Asteroiden behandelt. Ich weiß da nur, was da herausgekommen ist. Ähm äh und äh.
Ich denke mal, dass die eigentlich in einer äh Reichweite teilweise von Gaja sein müssten, aber sie sind äh im Moment äh.
Gibt es da keine Bahnbestimmung bei denen die Geierdaten irgendwie besser sind als das, was man bisher hatte. Das liegt auch vielleicht ein bisschen daran, dass sie sich sehr langsam bewegen, aber äh da bin ich jetzt auch nicht äh.
Genau informiert, inwieweit man von denen dann auch noch Bahnen erwarten kann,
Aber ich glaube, für diese Idee äh der nicht gleich Verteilung braucht man jetzt auch gar nicht größere Daten. Das das ist sozusagen da reichen die groben Daten, die man eigentlich hat, um diese Schlussfolgerung zu ziehen oder auch nicht.
Man müsste ihn einfach nur mal sehen. Das wäre äh ganz hilfreich,
Okay, also erstmal kein kein Planet neun. Ich setze mich wieder hin. Ein äh anderes ähm eine andere Art von Objekten, wo ja da ja auch so ein halbes Auge drauf geworfen hat, sind Ex-Planeten.
Da gab's ja so einige äh Hoffnungen, dass die eine oder andere äh Erkenntnis sich aus den Geierdaten herausziehen lässt. Gab's.
Also die die Idee ist auf jeden Fall, dass man ähm Exoplaneten in großer Zahl entdeckt, also so exoplaneten von der Masse.
Jupiter vielleicht ein bisschen dadrunter
ähm in der Sonnenumgebung und man hat abgeschätzt, dass man wahrscheinlich mit Gaja einige zehntausend von ihnen entdecken wird. Und zwar dadurch, dass der,
Stern, um den dieser Planetkreis, die bewegen sich ja gemeinsam um einen Schwerpunkt und das sorgt dafür, dass der Stern ein bisschen hin und her wackelt und das.
Macht man, was benutzt man ja oft dazu, dass man die Dopplereffekte nutzt, wie stark das Wackeln auf uns zu oder von uns weggeht, aber äh mit Gaja kann man eben auch die Querkomponente messen. Also man muss sich mal vorstellen, umgekehrt, wir würden unser Sonnensystem von
sagen wir mal zehn Pasek oder 30 Lichtjahre Entfernung betrachten. Was würde man an der Sonne sehen? Man würde an der Sonne sehen, dass die Sonne ein bisschen.
Hin und her wackelt und zwar auf einer relativ komplizierten Bahn, weil ja nicht nur der Jupiter als größtes massenreiches Objekt darum wandern würde, wenn man nur den hätte, dann wäre das eine Lipsenbahn,
um den gemeinsamen Schwerpunkt geht, aber da ist ja noch Saturn und andere Massereiche Objekte und insgesamt ist das eine recht komplizierte Bewegung.
Mal anguckt, wie groß die Amplitude von dort aus sind, dann ist das ungefähr eine Millibogen Sekunde. Von 30 Lichtjahren Entfernung, die Jupiter und Saturn
an an der Sonne hin und her ziehen würde,
Sekunde, das ist etwas, was für Gaja ja überhaupt kein Problem ist zu messen. Wir gehen ja in den Bereich von bei den besten Objekten so von 20 Mikrobogensekunden oder manchmal auch nur hundert
Mikrobogen je nach Genauigkeit. Das heißt also, wir können zehn bis äh
50 Mal besser messen als diese Milli-Bogen-Sekunde. Das heißt, wir können eine solche Bahn von der Sonne sehr genau äh detektieren und das können wir natürlich genauso erwarten, wenn wir einen Stern beobachten,
Nun muss man sich Folgendes klarmachen. Ähm im Fall der Sonne ist es ja zum Beispiel der Jupiter und der Jupiter bewegt sich nur alle zwölf Jahre um die Sonne herum.
Heißt auch diese Wackelbewegung, die ist sehr langsam. Das heißt, man braucht einen möglichst großen Messzeitraum, um eine solche Bewegung zu äh bekommen.
Und da sind die 34 Monate, die wir jetzt in dem Gaja DR drei drin haben, eigentlich ein sehr kurzer Zeitraum und es gibt tatsächlich Objekte, bei denen man das jetzt schon gemacht hat, aber eine kleine Zahl, also ich äh es ist in, also,
als ein Dutzend Objekte, wo man sowas messen konnte äh und Taiwan waren's auch bekannte Objekte, wo wir,
wo man zwar mit Hilfe vom Doppeleffekt gemessen hat, da ist ein Planet, aber das Masse man nicht bestimmen konnte, weil man
Bahn sozusagen nicht in der nur die Bewegung auf uns zu oder von uns wegbestimmen konnte, aber nicht deren äh Querbewegung, also die echte Bahn kennt und damit auch die Masse bestimmen konnte und das hat man jetzt mit Gaja in vielen Fällen machen können
und äh jetzt muss man leider in dem Fall bis zum Data-Release vier warten,
um jetzt für eine große Zahl und auch den entsprechend längeren Messzeitraum dann äh wirklich auch neue äh in größerer Zahl äh Exoplaneten in größerer Zahl zu entdecken. Da werden definitiv äh neue und in größerer Zahl Objekte.
Sein und ganz bestimmt in dem was dann
sozusagen am Ende der zehn Milliarden zehn Jahresmission für den finalen Sternkatalog herauskommen wird. Äh das wird also ein gewaltiger Datensatz, der dann
also auf jeden Fall wahrscheinlich mehr äh Exo Planeten aus Gaja
am Ende herauskommen wird als durch irgendwelche anderen Projekte. Also zumindest oder zumindest gleichziehen würdest, die anderen Projekte werden ja bis dann.
Genau so in der Kepler-Dimension wird ja ungefähr 5000 Exo Planeten bekannt und man schätzt eben wie gesagt ab, dass bei Gaja äh einige zehntausend Objekte herauskommen werden,
Wie gesagt, da muss man noch ein bisschen Geduld haben, um da äh sozusagen weitere
Erkenntnisse zu bekommen. Das Gleiche gilt für viele Doppelsterne, bei denen auch natürlich die längere Beobachtungszeit und viel mehr über deren Bahn äh verraten werden am Ende. Aber das da ist sozusagen im mit DR 3 der erste größere Datensatz und Doppelstern jetzt drin, aber,
kommt noch Einiges.
Bei den ich meine mit dem Jupiter ist natürlich so ein Beispiel so okay der Jupiter hat äh halt eine Umlaufzeit, die was war das 12 Jahre so ne, passt natürlich nicht so ganz äh hier ins Beuteschema andererseits das was ja bisher an Exoplaneten so beobachtet werden konnte
Man stellt ja.
Ganz genau, ob das sozusagen die Einschränkung der Beobachtung äh ist bisher, aber wir haben ja sehr viele äh Systeme beobachtet, wo es diese Hot Shupitas gibt, also die
quasi die Größe haben eines Jupiters, also entsprechend auch reißen an ihren Stellen, aber eben sehr viel näher dran sind, deswegen entsprechend heiß.
Absolut. Die werden auch leichter zu entdecken sein. Das ist ganz klar. Aber äh wie gesagt, ähm trotzdem ist es so, dass da ähm die Anzahl der der Entdeckung jetzt ähm im DR drei noch sehr, sehr begrenzt ist.
Ja ähm letztes Mal hatten wir noch kurz äh drüber gesprochen, dass es äh,
schwierig ist, sehr, sehr, sehr helle, sehr nahe Sterne äh zu mästen, weil dann sozusagen ja alles
so dermaßen überstrahlt wird, dass dann wiederum die äh Grenzen der äh der der Messinstrumente bei Geier überschritten werden, nicht unterschritten werden, sondern überschritten werden
die Hoffnung geäußert, dass man durch irgendwelche Tricks da vielleicht äh trotzdem noch zu Erkenntnissen kommen kann.
Also wir es ist so, dass wir
versprochen haben, am Anfang der Mission, dass wir eigentlich nur Sterne äh sehen werden mit Gaja oder in den Katalog haben müssen, die man mit bloßem Auge grade nicht mehr vom Erdboden aus erkennen kann. Das sind ungefähr die sechste Größenklasse
und äh was wir jetzt ähm in Gaja DR3 schon drin haben, sind Sterne, die äh drei Größenklassen
heller sind. Das ist äh jetzt weiß ich, drei Größen, das müsste ich mal schnell umrechnen. Das sind vielleicht irgendwie zwanzig Mal oder so ähm heller sind. Die kriegen wir also schon
ganz gut mit Gaja äh jetzt vermessen.
Aber die Hoffnung ist natürlich, dass man da noch mehr machen kann und da gibt es so ein paar Ideen, wie man das machen kann und äh auch Projekte, die von der Beobachtung her äh gemacht werden äh mit den Standardtechniken.
Einfach dies die in der in den astrometrischen CCDs die Objekte aufzunehmen wird das nicht klappen weil die hoffnungslos äh alles überbelichten.
Aber es gibt in dem äh in dem CCDs in den lichtempfindlichen Detektoren, die dafür zuständig sind, den Stern erstmal aufzufinden und zu sagen, wo ist jetzt eigentlich ein Stern in der Fokalebene, äh da gibt es ähm.
Ein Messgerät, welches auch äh mal für einige Sekunden und einige Minuten theoretisch äh.
Alle Sterne aufnehmen kann und dann sozusagen ein richtiges Bild vom von den Sternenregionen am Himmel erzeugen kann
und äh also so ein großes Fenster dran machen kann, was also nicht normalerweise vorgesehen ist,
und das wird standardmäßig für alle hellen Sterne regelmäßig gemacht. Äh das kostet natürlich zusätzliche Daten, aber da das wenige sind, das sind ja es handelt sich ja nur um ein paar hundert Sterne, die da äh so hell sind oder maximalen.
Vielleicht tausend Sterne. Äh das sind wenige am Himmel. Da kann man sich das denn leisten. Und da wird jetzt natürlich versucht, diese.
Hellen Sterne dann auch zu vermessen, aber das ist bisher noch nicht,
so in dem Maße gelungen, da eine gute Astrometride aus rauszumachen, die die man bräuchte, aber das ist in Arbeit und äh wie gut das sein wird, das wird man wahrscheinlich dann im nächsten Sternkatalog sehen
was da äh am Ende herauskommen kann.
Das sind also unsere Klassiker, ne, so Polarstern und äh Sirius.
Der Polarsterne ist so an der Grenze, da hat der zweite Größe, der ist nur ein Faktor zweieinhalb sozusagen von unserer bisherigen Grenzgröße entfernt und ich weiß nicht mal, ob dich.
Ich schätze mal vielleicht, den kann man vielleicht sogar klassisch noch am Ende vielleicht äh extra poliert kriegen, aber ähm Sterne, die heller sind, also Sirius ist einfach ein superheller Stimm.
Der der sorgt dafür, dass natürlich äh weite Bereiche äh überbelichtet sind und äh.
Macht die ganze Sache schwierig. Also die Hoffnung ist schon da und äh die da arbeiten auch sehr intelligente Leute dran, das zu machen, aber äh da kann ich nicht sagen, was da bisher dabei rausgekommen ist.
Ja ich gucke grad mal hier auf der Liste. Also Polarstern ist Platz 47 auf der Liste der hellsten Sternen unserer Wahrnehmung.
Ja gut, also ähm aber sagen wir mal die Hessen 100 werden wahrscheinlich immer noch eben Schwierigkeiten machen, würde ich jetzt mal sagen oder vielleicht auch 2hundert und.
Aber zweite Größe da kann man vielleicht schon noch hoffen, dass man da vielleicht irgendwie äh ein bisschen was machen kann.
Mhm. Ja mein äh mein Lieblings-Nebenspace, wenn ich meine Computer benenne, dann äh nehme ich mir immer Sternenname. Ja. Ja äh wäre ich ganz gut, wenn die auch mal alle vermessen sind, dann.
Übrigens äh auch die äh Computer im astronomischen Recheninstitut, die haben alle äh Sternennamen oder Himmelsobjekte zumindest.
Und äh.
Genau.
Und manchmal kann man natürlich tricksen, also ich bin ja äh beschäftige mich mehr zusätzlich mit Tunalismus, also der Erforschung von Entenhausen.
Tatsächlich. Mhm.
Und äh Erika Fuchs ist ja die berühmte Übersetzerin äh der Donald-Geschichten und ähm mein äh Computer heißt dort Erika Fuchs.
Essen und Erika Fuchs ist kein Stern, nein, aber es gibt ein Asteroiden, der nach ihr benannt wurde und weil natürlich äh es auch viele Fans
die dann astroid entdecken und die natürlich die Benahrung vorschlagen, genauso wie Karl Barrks, der die tollen Geschichten oder die besten Geschichten gezeichnet hat
am Himmel natürlich verewigt ist und dass mein Laptop dann äh
Karl Barks äh hieß oder heißt äh und ähm insofern kann man da so ein bisschen auch sich bei Himmelsobjekten so was äh aussuchen, weil viele Namen dann grade in die Asteroiden drin sind als Namen.
Drei eins eins sieben fünf Erika Fuchs. Äh nach dir ist noch keiner benannt.
Nach mir ist noch keiner genannt. Also wenn noch jemand entdeckt und äh den gern nach Wirbel nennen würde, ich wäre sehr froh, wenn das passiert.
Ja. Jetzt ähm.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz über die Datenbank äh reden. Ähm gab's noch so ein paar Sachen, die mir aufgefallen sind. Also es wird ja alles dann.
Wie wir schon erwähnt haben, Isak.
In Spanien vorgenommen, dass es ja quasi so das Servicezentrum für die Wissenschaft, habe ich auch jüngst einige Sendungen dort vor Ort aufgenommen, auch zu diesem äh Thema.
Dort landet das dann alles und äh bietet im.
Den Zugriff für, ja, jeden, ne? Also so ist ja nicht nur auf die Wissenschaft äh begrenzt. Da kann sich ja jeder einklinken. Ähm.
Gibt ja dann auch noch solche also erstmal hat der so jedes jedes Objekt hat ja dann so eine so eine eindeutige Kennung.
Ein paar Kennungen haben sich aber geändert jetzt irgendwie beim neuen Katalog. Warum.
Es gibt äh mehrere Gründe. Also zum Beispiel kann es manchmal sein, dass man herausfindet, dass ein Stern, der im Sternkatalog vorher.
Als ein Objekt gesehen wurde jetzt im neuen Katalog als zwei Objekte identifizieren muss, dass das ein Doppelstern ist. Da muss man natürlich.
Machen und dann muss man die ändern. Also die allermeisten Sterne haben ihre Identität übrigens behalten, aber für ein paar gilt das nicht und dann gibt's auch ein paar ganz wenige Sterne.
Gar keine Sterne waren, die nur ein Artifakt waren. Das kann auch passieren, dass das wird ein,
vielleicht zwei Prozent oder so der Sterne vielleicht mal eine Zahl in den Raum geschmissen ohne dass ich sie wirklich kenne aber äh das kann auch mal passieren und dann wird halt der Stern äh rausgenommen oder es werden neue gefunden in der Tat natürlich, weil
wir natürlich jetzt mehr Sterne im Katalog haben als im Vorgängerkatalog. All das sorgt dafür, dass wir eben ein paar neue Benennungen haben. Aber es gibt.
Datenbank äh eine Tabelle, in der Datenbank natürlich eine Tabelle, die die Identifizierung zwischen dem vorherigen Katalog und dem jetzigen natürlich äh sicherstellt.
Mhm. Eine andere Information ist äh eine eine Healpix äh Information, die so einen Stern auf die Erdoberfläche verortet, wie.
Ja also nicht.
Sind eigentlich nicht die Erdoberfläche, sondern es ist so, dass die Hirtes, äh Hirpix äh ist eine ein Verfahren, ein mathematisches Verfahren, die den Himmel in,
in gleichflächige äh gleiche Flächen einteilt. Eine Kugel oder ein äh ein Koordinatensystem, gleiche Flächen ein.
Und äh das ähm ist so, dass man Healpix verschiedene Stufen hat.
Je höher die Stufe, desto feiner ist diese Einteilung. Aber das besondere, es ist gar nicht so leicht eine Kugel äh in gleiche Flächen einzuteilen
Also das ist ja das Grundproblem, wie man das macht. Aber mit geht das und ähm man kann dann auch äh die in einer sehr systematischen Weise miteinander identifizieren, sodass man auch herauskriegen kann, welche Flächen miteinander benachbart sind anhand der.
Nummer, die dort gemacht wird. Und diese Nummer werden übrigens auch benutzt dann in Gaja, um die
Benennung der Sterne zu machen. Also da die Benennung der Sterne haben wir natürlich keine Eigennamen, das kann man bei 1,8 Milliarden Sternen schlicht vergessen da Einnahmen zu machen und äh früher hat man da Koordinaten genommen zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt.
Dass es auch sehr auch genauso unleserlich im Grunde genommen und auch ändert sich auch, weil man natürlich im Laufe der Zeit ändern sich Koordinaten, aber äh so leicht verlässt man nicht so ein und es ist einfach so, dass man die Nummer des in
in äh das Zahlensystem von null bis äh neun äh übersetzt sozusagen und äh in äh und dann durchnummeriert und das ist da müssen so viele Zahlen
drin sein, so dass man auch auskommt mit der Anzahl der Sterne, die dort drin sein könnten und äh das heißt, man kann anhand der Stern.
Benennung in Gaja, äh wenn man genau weiß, welche
welche äh wie viele Ziffern jetzt zu Healpix gehören und wie man das umrechnet äh kann man genau sagen zu welchem sozusagen ein bestimmter Bereich äh gehört. Das ist sehr nützlich, wenn man
Karten des Himmels machen möchte, weil man ja da zum Beispiel nicht jeden einzelnen Stern auftragen möchte, sondern wissen möchte, wie die dichte Verteilung der Sterne ist. Dann sind die sozusagen schon zusammengefasst zu Objekten, die eine bestimmte Größe in
ich sage jetzt mal Millibogen Sekunden haben,
und äh dann kann man sagen, wie viele Sterne zu diesem gehören, das steht im Sternkatalog ja drin, dann hat man die schon zusammengefasst und kann dann so eine Karte machen.
Und äh das ist also ein sehr nützliches System, um äh Sterne zu benennen und äh und äh.
Und ähm wissenschaftliche Karten äh darzustellen.
Und daraus ergibt sich sozusagen auch automatisch so eine äh so eine Baumstruktur äh in der quasi alle Sterne angelegt sind oder abgespeichert sind. Mhm.
Wurde zum Beispiel sehr viel gemacht äh bevor Gaja da war für die für die ähm Bilder von kosmischem Hintergrund. Da will man nämlich auch wissen, wie wie
die eine bestimmte Entfernung voneinander haben ähm miteinander korrigiert sind, weil man ja wissen möchte, welche.
Muster sich da in einem Hintergrund umgeben, die was mit der Dichtefluktuation im frühen Universum zu tun hat. Da da hat man das glaube ich zum ersten Mal großräumig benutzt in der Astronomie, aber
in in in der Astrometrie benutzt man das eben jetzt wie gesagt auch sehr.
Aber welche Form hat denn diese dieser Pixel? Also das ist ja dann kein Kreis, sondern es ist dann.
Nee, dass das so eine so eine.
Oder.
Ja, das das hängt ein bisschen davon ab, wo man am Himmel ist. Die ändert sich so ein bisschen. Das gibt eine schöne, gucken Sie einfach auf Wikipedia Healpics, da gibt es äh schöne Plots, wie das aussieht, denn glaube ich, sagt da ein Bild doch mehr, als sich das jetzt im Einzelnen beschreiben würde.
Sind gar nicht so viele schöne Bilder irgendwie hier. Nö, da ist nur so ein bisschen Projektion äh äh ist da und ansonsten noch ein bisschen Hintergrundstrahlung, also mehr ist da irgendwie nicht zu sehen, ne.
Unter Hilpics äh oder was? Okay.
Dann habe ich eine andere Webseite im Gedanken. Äh ja genau, dann war das gar nicht auf Wikipedia. Dann muss ich da muss ich vielleicht den Link äh irgendwie dir nennen, den ich von äh den ich dir dann einfach nochmal zuschicke. Dann kann sich das jeder gut angucken.
Wikipedia weiß auch nicht alles. Das haben wir haben wir den Beweis.
Jetzt haben wir eigentlich schon ganz äh gut alles abgeklappert, aber vielleicht gab's ja noch ein paar Studien so aus der letzten Zeit, die an dir vorbei geflogen sind, weil jetzt haben wir ja sehr viel darüber geredet, was sagt,
Datenbank selber aus und was hat sich.
Äh verbessert, aber interessant am Ende ist ja dann eben wirklich äh die Wissenschaft, die dabei herauskommt, dass sich jetzt also Wissenschaftler
stürzen und sagen, okay, alles klar, jetzt habe ich hier endlich mal die Datenbasis, mit der ich diesen Aspekt untersuchen kann. Ähm
So und hat's ja schon erwähnt, es gibt da so ein paar, die.
Scharren schon mit den Hufen und äh an dem Tag, wo die Daten rauskommen, wissen sie ganz genau, worauf sie schauen müssen und andere gucken dann halt überhaupt erst mal, ob sie was Interessantes finden, aber das findet ja die ganze Zeit statt
Gab's jetzt schon irgendwelche neuen Erkenntnisse in den letzten drei Jahren, die so auf äh Gaja basierten.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ein paar habe ich sozusagen indirekt schon erwähnt, wo man Genaueres machen kann mit den Sternströmen, mit den mit der mit der Frage, wie sich die äh.
Sterne verteilen, die wohl durch äh solche galaktischen ähm Begegnungen stattgefunden haben
Aber äh ja eine ganz neue Entdeckung, die auch vor vor wenigen Wochen durch die Presse ging, war zum Beispiel die Entdeckung eines eines Schwarzen Loches, welches das nächste Schwarze Loch ist in der Sonnenumgebung.
Und wo ein etwa sonnenähnlicher Stern innerhalb von äh ich weiß nicht wie viel.
Hundert Tagen, ich sage jetzt mal, 160 Tagen oder sowas, um äh die die um etwas kreist, was wo was dunkel ist und ähm
Das äh.
Waren Kandidat aus den Geierdaten für ein Schwarzes Loch, weil man sich nicht vorstellen kann, das muss ein Massenobjekt sein, was wahrscheinlich so was wie zehn Sonnenmassen hat.
Auf der Bewegung des des sonnenähnlichen Sterns bestimmen und was aber überhaupt nicht leuchtet.
Und da kommt äh einem eigentlich nur ein schwarzes Loch in in.
Als Möglichkeit, also von allen Objekten, die man kennt, sind schwarze Löcher. Das Einzige, was sozusagen damit kompati.
Äh es ist immer ein indirekter Beweis, solange man nicht so ein Bild vom von der von der von ja man.
Vor dem Schatten des Schwarzen Loches, wie wir's kennen, von so einem so einem supermassiven Schwarz und auch dieses viel, viel kleiner dieses Schwarze Loch wird es zehn Sonnenmassen hat, hat.
30 Kilometer Durchmesser. Das ist also was äh was kann man nicht
auch nicht von der Erde dann vermessen. Aber es ist eben irgendwie 16hundert Lichtjahre von der Erde entfernt und damit das nächste schwarze Loch, was man kennt und äh es ist ganz anders entdeckt worden als die meisten schwarzen Löcher, denn die meisten schwarzen Löcher ähm.
Entdeckt man dadurch, dass sie gar nicht so dunkel sind, dass Objekte Schwarze doch selber, das sieht man nicht, aber in der Umgebung von schwarzen Löchern tut sich meist einiges. Wenn da nämlich Materie.
In Richtung eines Schwarze Loches fließt, denn äh bildet sich um das Schwarze Loch so eine Scheibe von
durch die Drehimpulserhaltung, dass die um das Schwarze Loch hin nah und um äh rumfällt und die und das Gas, was da strömt, das reibt aneinander und dadurch entsteht Röntgenstrahlung und.
Den Quarzan.
Zum Beispiel bei den Quasanen ist das also das ähnliche Mechanismen. Und äh da.
Und da und das und gerade dieses wenn das Materie gefüttert wird dieses schwarze Loch, dann kann man das entdecken und dann kann man aufgrund der Eigenschaften auch sehen, dass das schwarzes Loch ist. Hier ist es so, dass wir tatsächlich
sozusagen ein Objekt haben, was eben nicht gefüttert wird durch.
Dunkle Materie, so ein ruhendes schwarzes Loch, wie man's da nennt. Äh ähm und das ist in insofern etwas sehr, sehr seltenes, was weil man davon noch nicht sehr viele entdeck.
Noch nicht so nah. Äh die Geier ähm Entdeckung selber reichte nicht aus, da hat man noch ein paar ähm äh.
Beobachtungen gemacht, um die Radialgeschwindigkeit zu messen mithilfe von sehr großen Teleskopen, von dem sonnähnlichen Stern, der da äh sich bewegte und ähm
zusammen mit diesem Vitting Gaya Beobachtung konnte man dann aber identifizieren, dass es sich um sein solches Zehn-Sonnenmassen schwarzes Loch äh.
Muss. Das sind übrigens Entdeckungen, wo auch äh.
Heidelberg beteiligt war, nämlich das Max-Punk-Institut für Astronomie äh ähm war da beteiligt und der Erstautor äh der auch in Harvard arbeitet äh und Max-Planck-Institut äh gearbeitet hat.
Der stammt eben auch von, hat diese Beobachtung dann mit seinem Team veröffentlicht und da waren wie gesagt auch einige äh
die dann die weiteren äh erdgebundenen Messungen zusammen, dass sie überhaupt etwas, was immer sehr wichtig ist, dieses Wechselspiel, äh man hat was Interessantes gefunden mit Gaja und manchmal braucht man noch ein paar zusätzliche Beobachtungen, dann kann man gucken, ob schon irgendwelche Beobachtungen gibt. Es gibt ja andere
die man vielleicht von den Sternen hat und äh das Tolle an solchen Datenbanken, das geht äh ging ja ein bisschen um das Thema Datenbanken, auch ist, dass man heute das viel leichter zusammenführen kann. Die Beobachtungen, die mit verschiedenen Instrumenten gemacht werden
kombinieren, um dann ein Gesamtbild von den Objekten, die man dort studiert, dann auch am Ende zu haben. Und ähm.
Ja, also äh die anderen Dinge habe ich glaube ich im Wesentlichen genannt, die jetzt ganz großräumig ähm sind.
Noch mal eine Frage zu diesem Schwarzen Loch. Also.
Gefunden hat man's, weil man einen Stern gefunden hat, der eine sehr enge Rotation um so einen Punkt äh hatte. Das ist ja etwas, was man eigentlich aus diesem Katalog sehr leicht herauslesen können müsste.
Heißt es dann nicht, dass man dann eigentlich relativ fix auch noch.
Tausend andere schwarze Löcher auf die Art und Weise äh finden kann oder ist das so selten, dass das jetzt hier so ein totaler Zufallsfund war, weil ich meine, das ist ja nun vergleichsweise einfacher
Parameter, den man hier finden kann, so eine Rotationsgeschichte aus den Bewegungsdaten, wie sie Gaja rausgibt zum.
Also ich bin an dem Projekt nicht selber beteiligt, dass sie, weiß ich nicht jetzt, wie viel Objekte sozusagen noch drinstecken geht. Ich kann mir aber gut vorstellen, dass sie in Geierdaten natürlich noch andere äh schwarze Löcher da drin sind, aber äh und ähm.
Aber diese eine Fund sozusagen hat sich schon gelohnt zu veröffentlichen an der.
Also ich bin bin mir sicher, dass in den Gaja-Daten noch mehr äh solche Objekte äh drin sind. Man muss natürlich auch für intelligente Weise die Daten filtern.
Und man muss sich immer klar machen die Geier Daten sind schon sehr komplex wenn man sich das genau anguckt. Eigentlich.
Sind so die wesentlichen astrometrischen Daten, da ist eine Position, da ist eine die Eigenbewegung, von denen wir geredet haben und dass die Paralaxe.
Das sind eigentlich fünf Werte übrigens, also zwei Koordinaten, mit denen man die Position beschreibt.
Zwei, die einem sagt, in welche wie schnell sich ein äh Objekt in diesen beiden Koordinaten pro Jahr bewegt und dann die Entfernung oder die Paralachse. Äh aber in Wirklichkeit ist es natürlich so, dass da die Messfehler
Korrelationen dieser Daten miteinander, also viele, viel mathematische Statistik über die Beobachtung selber mit drin ist und deshalb muss man eben sehr genau gucken, welche Daten sind jetzt genau auch signifikant für diese Sache.
Äh das macht die Filterung schwieriger, als wenn man jetzt einfach sagen würde, die Daten sind ja
so genau, dass alle äh alles andere vernachlässigt werden kann. Das heißt, man muss also erstmal eine grobe Filterung machen und gucken
welche als Kandidaten zur Verfügung steht und dann muss man sich jedes von diesen Daten sehr genau angucken, ob ob die einzelne Messungen auch zuverlässig sind, denn ähm da da gibt's aber viele Parameter in den Garten, Geierdaten, die einen
darüber Auskunft geben und in diesem Fall auch noch die Nachbeobachtung, die haben das ja dann auch noch gezeigt, dass da eine solche Bewegung stattfand, dann in der Kombination
konnte man das in diesem Fall schließen. Das heißt, es ist schon wahrscheinlich ein gewisser Aufwand damit zu verbunden, aber ich kann jetzt im Kopf nicht abschätzen, ob da ob man ob da jetzt zehn oder hundert oder tausend.
Solche schwarzen Löcher in den dreier Daten jetzt drinstecken. Dafür bin ich einfach zu weit weg von der eigentlichen Entdeckung in diesem Fall.
Na ja, ne. Ich freue mich ja jetzt auch eher, was das sozusagen für die Strategien in Zukunft aussagt, wie man denn nun sich sozusagen diesem Datenmaterial nähert. Ist klar, wenn man jetzt was.
Bestimmtes äh hat, dann freuen die sich so, ah hier endlich der Stern, äh auf den ich schon immer schaue
Mal äh genau oder die Gruppe oder was auch immer man da äh schon hat, aber das eigentlich Spannende ist ja äh
bisschen einfach die Angel in den Teich äh zu werfen und mal zu gucken, was so anbeißt. Ähm das dauert natürlich dann lange äh also möchte man äh eher so ein Netz ähm auslegen um dann äh nach interessanten Dingen zu fischen und das
natürlich so ein bisschen äh nach dieser Machine äh Technik, mit der man ja sind so diffusen Datenmaterial, bestimmte Muster äh dann eben auch trainieren kann, indem man quasi das Wissen, was man derzeit hat
quasi matcht auf diese Datenbank und sagt so okay, das damit trainiere ich jetzt sozusagen die alles was wahr ist und suche äh auf diese Art und Weise nach Neuem.
Absolut, also diese neuronalen Netzwerke oder ähnliche Techniken der künstlichen Intelligenz, um äh um Klassifikationen zu machen und in Datensätzen bestimmte Muster zu finden. Das ist natürlich hochgradig populär und,
ganz, ganz viele äh ähm wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichungen beruhen inzwischen auf solchen äh auf solchen Suchstrategien
und sie helfen auch zum Beispiel
herauszufiltern, welche gehören dazu und welche sind vielleicht Hintergrund oder Vordergrund er nicht dazu gehört, dass da dass es sehr, sehr hilfreich. Äh
Hinterher muss man natürlich dann immer auch gucken, eine Interpretation, denn das das Dumme an diesen Netzwerken ist, dass sie einem zwar irgendwie Objektlisten liefern, aber sie sagen einem nicht genau, warum dieses Objekt.
Gehört. Das ist ja ein bisschen das Problem dieser Art von Mustererkennung. Das heißt also äh da äh da aber zum
aber sie sind extrem populär und auch sehr extrem erfolgreich, um um bestimmte Daten auch äh herauszubekommen und zu klassifizieren und das wird zum Beispiel auch gemacht, um
äh um um diese äh Sternparameter, von denen ich sprach, die dann ja auch sozusagen veröffentlichen Temperatur
und ähm wir haben Massen und Leuchtkraft äh Bestimmungen und ähnliches, die die veröffentlicht sind. Da sind auch teilweise solche Strategien angewendet werden, um schnell für große Datensätze solche Parameter zu bestimmen.
Gibt sicherlich äh viele auch komplexe mathematische Herangehensweisen, was weiß ich, so Gravitationslinsen äh Effekte kann man ja im Prinzip dann auch.
Finden, ne, also.
Oh ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Schon sortiert sind sozusagen, weiß man ja okay, ich schaue mir jetzt mal irgendeinen Bereich an.
Verhalten sich hier bestimmte Sterne so, dass sie aussehen, als wären sie halt so langgezogene Dinger, ne. Ist das überhaupt mit solchen Sternen, die so durch so eine Gravitationslinse,
gar nicht mehr richtig punktförmig sind.
Gaja so etwas.
Ja, also bei Sternen, die äh einigermaßen weit noch von der Linse entfernt sind, ist diese Verzerrung eigentlich gering, aber
Positionsverschiebung, die kann man durchaus mit Gaja sehen, das heißt ähm also die meisten Gravitationslinsen, die man ja heute entdeckt vom Boden aus, äh indem man,
Millionen von Sternen jeden Tag nach der Helligkeit macht. Das sind Helligkeitsmessungen vor allen Dingen. Also da da sieht man, dass so eine Gravitationslinse, dass die Helligkeit eines äh.
Eines ähm durch einen vorbeifliegendes Objekt, was davorfliegt, äh die Helligkeit des Hintergrundobjektes äh verstärkt, um einigen.
Faktoren und äh das ist das, was man eigentlich hauptsächlich misst.
Mit Gaja kann man tatsächlich astrometrisch messen, wie die Sternposition, wenn du wenn man dann in die Nähe von der von dem Objekt kommt, misst und zwar über einen viel breiteren Bereich, während diese Linse
im Allgemeinen in der Helligkeit variiert über Monate hinweg.
Ist es so, dass man äh astrometrisch diesen Effekt schon über Jahre messen kann im Prinzip. Also über längeren Zeitraum, aber es ist natürlich komplizierter und viel schwieriger diese Messungen dann zu machen
Das beste ist natürlich man hat beides am Ende
Teilweise wird auch vorhergesagt aus der aus den Gajadaten, welche Objekte möglicherweise Kandidaten für eine Gravitationslinse sind. Das dazu muss man natürlich sehr genau die Positionen der Sterne äh kennen, die dort beteiligt sind. Also das
hätte man vorher gar nicht gewagt vor den Geierdaten, solche Vorhersagen zu machen.
Aber diese Verzerrung, die kommt eigentlich erst, wenn man ganz, ganz nah an die Linse rankommt und das ist ein so seltenes, ob die äh
Sachen und ich glaube, dass man mit Gaja solche Verzerrungen auch nicht messen könnte. Dafür fehlt uns auch die Auflösung
wir können zwar die Position sehr genau bestimmen aber machen ja keine tollen also wirklich Bilder von den Objekten in dem Sinne dass wir so etwas dann erkennen könnten.
Äh meine wirst ja sicherlich auch äh mit einigen mit mit offenstehendem Mund auf die äh Bilder geschaut haben, die jetzt vom James Web
Teleskop äh gekommen sind. Ich denke, dass soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, ist die Qualität dieses äh Teleskops ja da.
Besser als man's äh im besten Fall,
angenommen hat so. Das absolute Maximum was physikalisch möglich ist, wurde erreicht und jetzt
quasi auf Bilder die alles sprengen, was man sich so erhofft hat, oder.
Extrem eindrucksvoll und das James Web Teleskop äh auch wenn es sehr lange gedauert hat und alles war ist wirklich ein tolles Projekt und äh hat sich mit Sicherheit auch gelohnt und äh die die das was man so
außen, ich bin ja nicht jetzt an diesem Projekt selber beteiligt, aber was was man so hört ist und was man sieht äh auch an tollen Bildern, wo man dann
ja in Bereiche reinsehen kann, wo man im Optischen einfach nicht reingucken kann, weil da die Intersteller Materie davor.
Dahinter liegenden Objekte ja verschluckt und mit der Wärmestrahlung, die er von von dem gemessen wird, kann man da teilweise reingucken und äh und in Auflösungen, die auch besser sind, wobei man natürlich immer sagen muss.
Ähm äh sagen wir dem Infraroten beobachtet, braucht man auch ein größeres Teleskop, um die gleiche Auflösung zu erzielen, die man im Optischen hat, weil,
die äh die Auflösung sinkt ja mit der Wellenlänge linear, also je äh bei der doppelten Wellenlänge hat man auch nur das halbe Auflösungsvermögen an der Stelle, aber das äh,
Ist wirklich äh extrem eindrucksvoll, was man damit äh James Web äh machen kann.
Mit Geier gibt's ja eigentlich nur im Bereich der Beobachtung der Exoplaneten dann, ne.
Ja, ganz sicher, dich jetzt Überschneidung geben, aber der Punkt ist ähm angenommen, es gibt ein interessantes Objekt, was man mit James Web entdeckt.
Man braucht das da die Entfernung, die kann dem nicht messen.
Wir können es auch mit Gaja sehen. Das ist natürlich Voraussetzung. Also es darf nicht so ein Objekt sein, was wo das Licht verschluckt wird durch irgendwie äh Dunkelwolken und äh das ist ein Objekt, was Mobige gar nicht sehen kann, aber wenn wir das mit Geier sehen können und mit
James Wrap wurden irgendwelche Erkenntnisse gewonnen über das Objekt, dann ist die Entfernungsmessung zum Beispiel immer noch ein zusätzlicher Parameter, der einem auch für die äh Beurteilung und die Erforschung mit James Bab hilft
Also immer die Kombination verschiedener Beobachtungen helfen weiter. Gaja ist manchmal nur ein ein Mosaikstein für ein Paper, manchmal auch
Wichtigste für eine.
Zumindest der Startpunkt, ne.
Das ist der Start auf der Startpunkt, aber äh zusammen mit James Web äh Beobachtung kann das auch sehr nützlich sein.
Paper sind denn jetzt so rausgekommen, die man auf Gaja zurückführen kann? Letztes Mal hatten wir tausendsiebenhundert, da hast du gesagt, das war so vier pro Tag.
Wir sind also in den äh ja wir sind ungefähr bei fünf äh Veröffentlichungen seit dem Veröffentlichung des zweiten Sternkatalogs sind wir bei fünf Veröffentlichungen pro Tag ungefähr.
Das ist sehr, sehr konstant geblieben und äh ähm hat ist es äh ist wirklich eindrucksvoll
also und äh der der etwas, was ähm wirklich ganz, ganz selten ist, dass wir Dob von der NASA bekommen.
Also ich meine, die Amerikaner äh sind ja manchmal sehr äh zentriert auf das, was NASA macht und so. Aber der Wissenschaftsdirektor der NASA, der hat
in einem Tweet letztens äh geschrieben,
im letzten Jahr Gaja, was die für Anzahl der Veröffentlichung pro Jahr angeht, äh habe es Base Teleskop geschlagen hat, was bisher das erfolgreichste.
Was die Anzahl der Wissenschaft Paper angeht und darauf sind wir natürlich sehr, sehr stolz und auch, dass das sozusagen von der Nase auch wirklich angenommen wurde und.
Ganz tolle Sache ist, dass jetzt im äh Gaja einen Preis bekommen hat und zwar auch von einer amerikanischen Organisation, das ist der Barkley-Price, Preis der äh verliehen werden wird im.
Glaube im Januar oder im Januar wahrscheinlich nächstes Jahres auf der Tagung der äh amerikanischen astronomischen Gesellschaft. Dort wird dieser Preis verliehen und zwar für das Gajaprojekt und.
Auch sehr schön, dass da äh wir da die Sichtbarkeit äh haben und äh das auch wahrgenommen wird und.
Wenn wir uns angucken, wer die Daten abruft, ist Amerika, USA äh so sehr, sehr weit auch äh dabei, die die europäischen Daten zu sehen und ich höre das auch, wenn ich auf Tagung bin. Ich war auf einer Tagung über weiße Zwerge, bei denen Gaja natürlich übrigens eine enorme Rolle spielt äh äh
wo viele amerikanische Wissenschaftler auch waren und die natürlich Gaja extensiv äh und also intensiv
benutzen und äh in in vollem Umfang natürlich auch äh auswerten. Also etwa 5 Prozent aller Paper war sind übrigens über weiße Zwerge, mein die
Lieblingsgebiet, mit dem ich mich wissenschaftlich lange beschäftigt habe und da gibt es auch viele neue Erkenntnisse, also zum Beispiel über.
Kristallisation von weißen Zwergen, das sind Dinge, die die man erst mit den Geierdaten jetzt auch auf Tipp, obwohl vorher theoretisch vorhergesagt äh sehr sehr genau
ja zeigen kann, dass es wirklich passiert genau dieser Vorgang während weiße Zwerge, die ja im Inneren keine Kernfusion mehr machen, sich abkühlen
so einen bestimmten Zeitpunkt, wo die Kristallisieren und dann nochmal bisschen latente Wärme freisetzen, wie wir's bei jedem Kristallisationsprozess stattfindet und
kann man an bestimmten Diagrammen äh erkennen, dass das äh und zwar nur durch die
Gaja äh Daten äh zusammen mit anderen Messungen, aber durch die Gaja-Informationen ist man in der Lage, diese dieses diesen diese Sache auch wirklich nachzuweisen. Also
Es ist man kann eigentlich in jedes Gebiet, auf dem man sich ein bisschen auskennt, hineingehen und sagen, Gaja hat da
unglaubliches geleistet und das finde ich ist auch so mit eins der spannendsten Dinge, dass Gaja nicht für
für Asteroiden gemacht oder für Sterne oder für sondern für alles.
Auf all diesen Gebieten leistet Gaja enorme Sachen. So ein bisschen ja so eine eierlegende Wollmilchsau in gewisser Weise. Äh was das angeht.
Gibt's eigentlich Missionen, die so.
Ich meine der Bedarf so eine Mission wie Gaja nochmal zu wiederholen, der wird jetzt erstmal.
Nicht so groß sein, weil es ja absehbar ist, dass jetzt mit zehn Jahre Beobachtungszeit, so also bis man diesen Katalog überhaupt erst mal extensiv ähm.
Durch hat, so also da gibt's wahrscheinlich gar nicht genug Wissenschaftler. Ich wollte schon das Gefühl, um das sozusagen äh alles rauszuholen, wird ja auch äh Huble hat ja auch noch irgendwie genug Arbeit für für viele. Aber so dieses.
Beobachtungsprinzip.
Die wir Art und Weise, wie diese Raumsonde auch funktioniert, das mag ja dann auch für andere als artige Beobachtungen und Katalogisierungen, die sich.
Andere Aspekte anschaut, vielleicht auch interessant sein. Gibt's irgendetwas, was man so in puncto Nachfolgemission oder äh verwandte Mission dort schon diskutiert.
Das gibt's natürlich, also es ist ja so, dass äh die ersten sehr konkreten Ideen für eine neue Mission, die dann später Gaja genannt wurde, äh äh kam, als die Hyperkostmission zu Ende war
1993 war die der etwa hunderttausend Sterne vermessen hat äh hochgenau und äh einige
mit etwas niedriger äh Genauigkeit ähm hat dann gerade seine die Beobachtungen beendet und wurde dann ausgewertet.
Der Datensatz und da kam dann ja auch die Ideen und sehr konkrete
Vorschläge für die Konstruktion eines neuen Gerätes und so ist es natürlich auch jetzt äh dass äh schon während der Mission natürlich Ideen sind für eine Nachfolgemission. Also dieses Prinzip eines Scanningsattelliten.
Das ist tatsächlich eins, was extrem gut ist für für Astrometrie, also das ist schon sehr sehr äh für diesen Zweck äh gemacht worden.
Und ähm die Idee für einen Gaja-Nachfolgemission ist, dass man.
Da auch so ein bisschen ins Infrarote geht, um nämlich äh zu vermeiden, dass man die Sterne, die man ja aufgrund der Interstelle an Materie durch die Absorption nicht sieht
man die ein bisschen ähm da dass man da mehr Objekte bekommt.
Ein also eine würde mehr Infraroten beobachten. Das sind noch einige technische Probleme zu lösen. Das ist äh nämlich die Ditektoren äh,
genauso arbeiten, wie man für so einen Scanning-Sathliten braucht. Die gibt es bisher für für Infrarot noch nicht. Aber prinzipiell kann das möglich sein. Da werden Studien gemacht, die auch.
Gerade auch schon anlaufen oder demnächst anlaufen. Und interessanterweise hat bei der Veröffentlichung vom
DR 3 die offizielle Veranstaltung der ESA. Da hat er ähm ja Wissenschaftsdirektor der ESA der Professor Günther Hasinger
genau dieses Projekt eines Nachfolgers schon erwähnt und dass es offenbar auch in der durchaus äh ja sehr,
populär ist, gerade wegen des großen Erfolges von Gaja.
Mit einem gewissen zeitlichen Abstand ist es durchaus sinnvoll, Gaja einen Gaja-Nachfolge auf äh zu machen, wo auch Astrometrie wieder eine Rolle spielen wird.
Eben dann im Infraroten und äh ich
denke mal, aber das die Realisierung wird wahrscheinlich eher so im Bereich zwanzig, 30 Jahre sein. Äh das sind natürlich Zeithorizonte, die dann eben auch da eine Rolle spielen, aber äh das wird natürlich jetzt äh untersucht, um dann
später äh so ein Projekt zu gegebener Zeit, wenn dann die Technik und auch.
Konstruktion eines solchen Satelliten und äh in der Konkurrenz mit anderen Projekten dann äh wieder so ein Projekt für,
notwendig genug gehalten wird, um es dann auch zu finanzieren.
Ja, das war so der Zeitraum, an den ich auch äh dachte, ist klar, dass das nicht von heute auf morgen äh.
Also Gaja Nier heißt das im Moment, aber ich meine, es wird mit Sicherheit nicht Gaja heißen und auch nicht Gaja, aber es gibt ja immer erstmal so einen Titel, dann weiß man, wo's.
Gemeint ist so, ne? Ja, ich meine, das hat man ja schön gesehen, jetzt, wenn man die Bilder äh von äh Jim Step vergleicht.
Aufnahmen von Huble, vom selben Ort. Wie
dass ja die Wahrnehmung der Geräte nochmal komplett ändert in dem Moment, wo man halt Infrarot draufgeht. Also alles, was so Dickicht und Nebel war, ja, so hier ähm wie heißt auch gleich hier diese Geburts äh Galaxie ähm.
Säulen der äh der Schöpfung, genau. Ja, pathetischer hätte man's jetzt kaum bezeichnen können, so.
Das stimmt. Im im Adlernebel eine Struktur ja.
Genau so und und äh ne und und James.
Schaut halt einfach durch den Vorhang und und und blickt auch noch mal auf äh andere Sachen. Aber verstehe ich das auch richtig, dass das sozusagen auf der einen Seite eben quasi den Blick in die Milchstraße eröffnen wurde, so insbesondere durchs Zentrum hindurch.
Aber letztlich ja vielleicht auch eine Astrometrie von ferneren Galaxien und so weiter auch noch äh mit befördern könnte, so wie James Welp das macht.
Ja, also ich glaube, durch das Milchstraßenzentrum sehr hindurch oder so, das werden wenige Objekte sein, das ist schon sehr, sehr dicht dort, aber man wird also deutlich erweitert und deutlich weiter auch Richtung galaktisches Zentrum gucken können damit.
Meine ich jetzt überhaupt sozusagen in in dieser Richtung.
Ja, ja, da wird
man sehr, sehr viel mehr sehen äh in dem Bereich und andere Galaxien, äh die also stärker in Richtung Infraroten sind. Das hängt natürlich davon ab, wie groß so ein Teleskop ist. Ich meine, man man muss ja auch noch bedenken, dass äh wenn wir jetzt äh in
den Zeitraum fünfundzwanzig, 30 Jahre denken, dass dann vielleicht ein Teleskop äh von erheblich größerer Größe
kein Problem sein wird, weil einfach vielleicht die Raumfahrt auch billiger wird und man dann also äh ja nicht so viel an äh ja.
Die Begrenzung war ja zum Beispiel bei Gaia, dass es in der Sojus äh reinpassen muss
mit der Faltung des Sonnenschirms und solche Dinge. Das wird natürlich ganz enorm natürlich helfen, wenn man da größer und äh mehr ins Infrarote gehen können. Da ist natürlich einiges möglich an an neuen äh Objekten, die man dann sehen kann.
Schneller, weiter.
Genau, das ist, die Wunschträume sind natürlich schon jetzt gigantisch, aber es wird bei in vielen Sinne länger dauern, aber was eben jetzt äh möglich geworden ist, ist wirklich enorm äh eindrucksvoll.
Ja bedanke mich für die auch eindrucksvolle Schilderung der Fortschritte und wir haben ganz gut angeschlossen finde ich in die letzte Sendung nochmal so einige neue Aspekte äh aufgemacht, die wir so letzte Mal noch gar nicht abgeklappert hatten.
Vielen Dank. Wir waren.
Ich bedanke mich und ich freue mich immer, wenn ich ein bisschen was über.
Unser spannendes Projekt erzählen kann, denn äh anders als äh James Web, wo man natürlich ganz leicht mit in die.
In die Nachrichten oder in die äh Tage, in die in die Webseiten, in die äh Tageszeitung kommen kann, wenn da ein tolles Bild äh veröffentlicht worden sind, haben wir's mit Gaja doch ein bisschen schwerer, weil wir eben keine tollen Bilder machen
auch mit Simulation, man kann im Internet auf YouTube.
Auch viele schöne Darstellung finden. Die sind aber meist computergeneriert, die dann aus den Daten hervorgegangen haben wir es da deutlich schwerer, aber wann immer man über dieses Projekt redet äh und Zuhörer hat, die sieht.
Die ähm ja lernen zum ersten Mal was über dieses.
Da hört man ganz oft Mensch äh ich hätte da viel früher gerne was drüber gehört und äh und ähm ja wir es ist schön, wenn wir so ein bisschen die Anzahl der Leute, die mit dem Gayer Projekt was anfangen kann.
Verbreitern und da danke ich ganz herzlich auch für dieses sehr angenehme Gespräch.
Na klar. Macht nur weiter schöne, viele Videos von diesen Sternenströmen ist äh das ist auf jeden Fall ausreichend sexy.
Ja, dann bleibt mir nur noch mich fürs Zuhören zu bedanken. Das war's heute von Raumzeit. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.